Keine Ahnung, Viertelstunde oder so.
Ja, wir sind heute relativ früh.
Das stimmt.
Sekunde, erst mal das Kabel hier.
Also erst mal ein Headset, Moment, ich muss mal kurz mein Headset entwirren.
Das ist, das ist, das hat eigentlich glaube ich ein, was sind das, ein 3 Meter Kabel oder ein 4 Meter Kabel.
Das ist quasi noch ein Meter lang gerade.
Ein bisschen durcheinander.
So, so, perfekt.
Aha, jetzt, jetzt stimmt es auch, jetzt stimmt auch der Sound links und rechts wieder.
Da war die ganze Zeit irgendwie ein bisschen linkslastig, ja.
So, exellent.
Auf geht's Leute, auf geht's.
MonkaS.
Erst mal was trinke.
Zähne gebunden, nö.
Ich bin direkt, ich bin aufgestanden und jetzt direkt an den Rechner.
Ich hab nix gemacht.
Ah ja, muss ich übrigens was zeigen.
Was?
Sonntag um 9.30, du willst es aber wissen.
So, muss ich euch was zeigen, aber erst mal weiß ich, irgendwie habe ich schon was im Halsseck.
So, exellent.
Okay, ja, ich muss euch was zeigen.
Muss ich die Musik ein bisschen leiser machen.
Muss ich euch was zeigen.
Erinnert ihr euch noch an den Stream, wo wir, nein, mich nervt das neue Twitch-Extreme hier, dass man nicht direkt muten kann.
Ihr erinnert euch ja bestimmt noch ans China-Chinesen-Geräte-Flaschen.
Diese Dinger hier, wo der Chat sich so gefreut hat, dass ich die kaputt gemacht hab.
So, und die gingen ja nicht, ne.
Und ich hab dem Entwickler drei Geräte zum Testen geschickt.
Und dreimal dürft ihr raten.
Äh, die ATC hieß das, glaube ich.
Und dreimal dürft ihr raten, was gestern gepatcht wurde.
Edit B16-Support, das heißt, wir können den Kram jetzt flashen.
Ich hab das nur mitbekommen, weil er mich gestern auf Twitter angeschrieben hat, so, so, so, danke für die Donation.
Hab ich halt nochmal geantwortet, danke für die Firmware.
Und jetzt ist es auch supported.
Es gibt allerdings wohl noch eine noch neuere Revision, die ist noch nicht supported.
Was sind das für Dinger?
Das sind Thermostate oder Thermometer oder wie auch immer man das.
Das ist Luftfeuchtigkeit und Temperatur.
Und das Gute ist, in Kombination mit der Custom-Firmware ist der Batterieverbrauch relativ gering.
Normalerweise announce das Ding irgendwie alle 5 Sekunden oder so die Werte per Bluetooth,
was natürlich viel zu viel ist, was interessiert mich 5 genau über Wireless, das Temperatur und Luftfeuchtigkeit.
Wenn du das aber runterstellst, sagen wir auf 5 Minuten oder so, dann hält die Batterie wirklich,
naja, ewig ist zu viel gesagt, aber ziemlich lang.
Normalerweise ist die Batterie nach einem halben Jahr leer.
Ich habe eh das Gefühl, die China-Chinesen-Geräte gehen viel zu verschwenderisch mit der Default-Firmware, mit der Batterie um.
Und wenn du das auf 5 Minuten stellst, also ich habe das jetzt fast ein Jahr oder so, würde ich sagen, im Einsatz.
Oder ein Jahr im Einsatz ungefähr.
Und ich bin jetzt glaube ich auf 78% Batterie und normalerweise ist es nach einem halben Jahr leer.
Also das ist schon, das ist schon ein riesen Unterschied mit Custom-Firmware oder nicht.
Also YouTube, was legst du uns denn heute vor?
Was Dragon Age Origin, was zum, warum ist das Video 3 Stunden 47 Minuten?
What the fuck, was geht mit den Leuten ab?
In der Zeit kannst du ja quasi fast schon Herr der Ringe uncut, naja, gut übertrieben, nein, kannst du nicht.
Wie lang ist Herr der Ringe Trilogie Directors Cut, das ist irgendwie 8 Stunden oder so oder neuneinhalb oder irgendwie sowas.
Aber 3 Stunden 47, was hältst du von Donald Trumps Social Media, habe ich noch null damit zu tun gehabt, bin schon null in Berührung gekommen, keine Ahnung.
Wurde es nicht gehackerment letztens?
Ich habe irgendwas, ich habe auf irgendeiner Newsseite gelesen, dass es gehackerment war.
Ich kann im Prinzip, kann ich ganz kurz dazu sagen, ja Dragon Age ist so gut, wie man das erinnert, vielleicht sogar besser.
Dragon Age ist das originale Dragon Age, alle anderen kannst du vergessen.
Das echt gut, das war so die optimale Kombination, finde ich aus Einsteigerfreundlichkeit im Vergleich zu den alten Sachen wie Baldur's Gate und sowas.
Die waren ja schon ein bisschen undurchsichtiger.
Und ich muss sagen, also eine Sache, die mir bei Dragon Age wirklich in Erinnerung geblieben ist, beim originalen Dragon Age wohlgemerkt, dass das ganz gut geschrieben war.
Also sowohl die ganzen Dialoge waren halbwegs konsistent, also du hast gemerkt, das war jetzt nicht irgendwie einmal irgendwie nur alles umschrieben und einmal voll direkt in your face.
Was mich ja ein bisschen bei den, ich habe jetzt das letzte Pathfinder-Game gespielt und da waren die Quest-Texte sehr, wie sagt man sowieso, all over the place.
Die einmal waren die Quest-Texte übelst direkt, auch mit F-Wörtern und allem Möglichen dabei und einmal halt total umschrieben, sehr komisch.
Also wie es ist geschrieben, also die ganzen Texte in Dragon Age Origins fand ich ziemlich gut.
Und was mir auch positiv in Erinnerung geblieben ist, dass du in den Dialogoptionen eigentlich fast immer das antworten konntest, was du auch antworten wolltest.
Ihr kennt ja vielleicht so RPGs, wo dich dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, irgendein NPC fragt dich was.
So nach dem Motto, wie fandest du das? Ja ganz gut, scheiße oder geht so?
So in Wirklichkeit willst du eigentlich antworten, alter NPC gehen wir nicht auf den Sack oder kannst du nicht.
Und in Dragon Age war das in der Regel eigentlich fast immer so, dass du in den Antworten das gefunden hast, was du dir gerade gedacht hast, das fand ich echt gut.
Zumal man auch sagen muss, die Companions waren übelst, war übelst nice.
Auch wenn die Companion-Quests ein bisschen kurz waren insgesamt, die sind ein bisschen sehr kurz gekommen, aber insgesamt fand ich, also muss man sagen, bei Dragon Age wirklich gut.
Ja.
Dragon Age ist von wann? Von 2009 oder so?
Wann kam das raus?
Nicht neun, 2009.
Nee, doch, ja doch, 2009.
Das ist echt ganz gut gealtert, das kann man heute noch spielen.
Ja, aber das ist auch eindeutig das beste Dragon Age.
Zwei kannst du vergessen.
Ähm, was kam danach? Inquisition? Nee.
Nee, was war das?
Ich leg hier nicht mehr durch.
Es gab Dragon Age, Dragon Age 2, das erste hat noch einen Addon, das hab ich nie gespielt.
Äh, kam dann Inquisition?
Mal kurz gucken, ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher.
Ach, jetzt soll ja Dragon Age 4 irgendwann kommen, genau.
Ja, ja ja, mal gucken, stimmt, das war Inquisition.
Heute Hetzer Teil 3, Hetzer Teil 3 kommt tatsächlich in nächster Zeit, weil ich hab am Freitag, wann das war, mit Hetzer telefoniert.
Und wir machen demnächst noch ein bisschen was.
Da bietet sich das an, und schon wieder der Typ.
Ich hab mir jetzt schon zweimal angeguckt, wie die Kekonahäuser mit der Segellöcher in die Wand geschnitten werden.
Nee, nee, Carl, vielleicht findest du es ab.
Ja, aber Dragon Age Origins war echt gut.
Ich bin ja immer noch ein bisschen traurig, dass man Wind nicht romanzen konnte.
Ich brauch hier irgendwas auch mal. Guck mal, es gibt so selten was in meinem Alter in so Games, ja.
Und da gab es wenigstens mal was, aber nein, geht nicht, geht nicht.
Wobei ich glaube, Wind war in dem Game irgendwie 50 oder so.
Vielleicht dann doch ein bisschen zu alt.
Aber es ist ja ein RPG, ja.
Roleplaying.
So, was kriegen wir hier noch? Schönes angezeigt, nix.
Do not design your network like this.
Das ist ja auch der krasseste Clickbait-Titel aller Seiten.
Ich mein, warum, warum nicht?
Warum sollte ich nicht ein Kabel zwischen den zwei Switchen stecken?
Das haben wir schon geguckt.
Tja.
Muss man sagen.
New World, drei Gründe gegen den Hype.
Na gut.
Das alte einfachste Grund gegen den Hype ist New World sucked.
Das kommt jetzt ja immer mehr raus.
By the way, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ich hab sie, weil ich sie nebenbei auf hab. Schaut mal.
Passt mal auf, ich muss es mal reloaden.
Also, es ist ja normal, dass nach einem MMO-Launch die Leute dann aufhören zu spielen.
Aber das ist ja eines der krassesten Drops, die ich in kurzer Zeit gesehen hab.
Ich mein, guck mal.
Die waren hier bei knapp einer Million.
Na ja, okay.
Sagen wir mal.
Bei 900.000 sind die, okay?
Und jetzt sind die bei 480.000.
Die haben, wenn man mal, warten wir mal heute ab.
Aber letzten Sonntag war es auch nicht, war es auch nicht so viel.
Was?
600.000.
Die sind, diesen Sonntag sind die wahrscheinlich bei 500.000 oder so was.
Das heißt, die haben ungefähr 40 bis 50% verloren.
Das ist richtig.
Man sieht es ja auch hier.
All time peak, 24 hour peak.
Hier sieht man das eigentlich ganz gut, wie viel die verloren haben.
Also, die haben es so verschissen.
Das ist genau das, es ist exakt das, was ich gesagt hab.
Die ganzen Leute, die jetzt New World spielen, wissen gar nicht, dass sie das eigentlich nicht spielen wollen.
Die spielen das nur wegen ihrem Lieblingsstreamer.
So.
Und dazu kommt, ich hab sogar, glaub ich, ein Video dazu auf.
Das können wir uns mal angucken.
Ja, das da.
Das ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Dass New World wirklich einige ganz große Probleme drin hat.
Zum Beispiel, muss ich eine Sache spoilern.
Da kommt noch viel mehr.
Zum Beispiel, dass die Sachen kleinzeitig checken.
Nein.
Aber 40% sind doch nicht normal.
Also, meinen, im Monat spielen die Leute wenigstens.
Aber 40% ist nicht normal.
40% ist richtig, richtig krass.
Was genau checken die kleinzeitig?
Ja, also, die checken ein paar Sachen kleinzeitig.
Zum Beispiel, ähm...
Geschwindigkeit.
Wir müssen uns das Video angucken.
Wir gucken uns das Video an.
Bewegungsgeschwindigkeit ist kleinzeitig.
Also, du kannst die easiest fucks speedhacken.
Weil das Ding, oder was ist Bewegungsgeschwindigkeit?
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich Koordinaten werden irgendwie mehr oder weniger ungefragt übernommen.
Also, du kannst easy speedhacken.
Du kannst dein Interface, kannst du umstellen.
Dass du, glaub ich, sogar die Fraktion wechseln kannst oder sowas.
Dass du Bonus bekommst, obwohl du gar nicht in der Fraktion bist.
Aber wisst ihr, was das Schlimmste eines der abgefucktesten Dinger in New World ist?
Ihr wisst ja, ich hab nur die Bilder gespielt.
Ich wusste gleich, ich will das nicht spielen.
Eines der abgefucktesten Dinger, die ich je in einem MMO gesehen hab, ist folgendes.
In New World gibt es ja drei verschiedene Factions.
Kurz, die muss ich weiter anlassen.
Im Kern eigentlich sollte das mal ein PvP-Game sein mit drei unterschiedlichen Fraktionen.
So, und jetzt ist halt das Problem, dass wenn irgendwie so ein Fraktionskrieg ist,
dass dann die eine Fraktion quasi die Leader der anderen Fraktion mess reported
und Amazon hat irgendein automatisches Reporting-Analysesystem.
Und wenn ein Spieler zu oft reported wird, dann wird er automatisch für 24 Stunden gebannt.
Und du kannst es zwar appealen, aber der appeal dauert länger als 24 Stunden.
Das heißt, die gegnerische, also die Fraktion, die bannen sich jetzt gegenseitig für 24 Stunden,
dass sie in dem jeweiligen Faction War gewinnen.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Wie abgefuckt kann eigentlich das System von einem MMO sein?
Die Leute imbüren das Bandsystem, wo das funktioniert.
Das ist schon echt der Wahnsinn.
Also, dass die das sehen gekriegt haben.
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Es gibt noch mehr Bugs.
Du kannst zum Beispiel Area-Effekte stacken oder Contest-Area-Effekte stacken.
Und das hat alles one-hitted und so was.
War ganz, ganz, ganz komisch.
Wir gucken uns das Video einfach an.
Ich denke mal, das meiste davon wird da auch erzählen.
Ich habe schon mal kurz reingeguckt.
Aber der zeigt hier irgendwann auch, was kleinzeitig ist.
Es sind einige Sachen in New World kleinzeitig.
Einige Sachen, wo man sich echt wundert.
Ich bin ja schon quasi bekannt als New World-Hater,
weil ich werde ja mittlerweile schon auf Twitter geflamed,
dass ich New World dabei habe.
Also sage ich ja immer, dass das meine Meinung ist.
Und Sachen, die objektiv halt scheiße sind.
Dass man kleinzeitig Bewegungsspeed, quasi ungefragt,
irgendwie auf das ist halt dumm.
Naja, so.
Muss einmal Sound anstellen.
Ach ja, ach ja, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss,
Moment, Moment, Leute, ich muss euch was zeigen.
Die Fanbase, die Fanbase von New World.
Sekunde.
Twitter, New World Deutschland.
Die Leute sind so
cringe, wie soll ich sagen,
so cringe, pepega,
realitätsignorierend.
Das kann ich,
das verstehe ich nicht.
Moment, Shopupdate,
Halloween-Geschenk.
Ach ja, es gab übrigens auch ein Bug mit Server-Transfer.
Man konnte, wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe,
mit einem Server-Transfer, man konnte
quasi sein Geld sinngemäß,
irgendwie sein Geld traden auf seinem alten Server.
Dann konnte man umziehen
und auf dem neuen Server und das Geld
wurde quasi nicht gespeichert.
Also sprich, man hatte das Geld auf dem alten Server
und dann hat man das Geld wieder auf dem neuen Server
und dann konnte man das irgendwie hin und zurück
transfern und dann konnte das Geld Gold duken.
Hier, hier.
So, also.
Schaut euch mal die Pepega-Community an.
Ah.
Ich mein, guckt euch mal solche Posts an, ja.
Die hatten jetzt das, also,
ihnen sind 40% Spieler weggerannt
und es gibt jetzt ein kostenloses Emote,
das quasi nochmal, ja, hervorhebt,
dass man jetzt zwei Wochen lang die Server nicht richtig verwenden konnte.
So, und da gibt es Leute, die antworten allen ernst,
das ist so Paynes-Champ,
dann antworten die, die meinen das ernst, die Leute.
Wow, sehr nice, danke.
Finde es unfassbar toll, was ihr alles leistet.
Ihr gebt euch so viel Mühe,
dass wir ein gutes Spielerlebnis haben
und dann wird uns auch noch was geschenkt.
Herzchen.
Oh.
Ah.
Da kriege ich Anfälle,
wenn ich so Sachen lese, Alter, das ist der Wahnsinn.
Okay, ich muss das, muss das wieder zumachen.
Das ist echt...
Was ist daran jetzt so schlimm,
dass sie sich auch noch freuen,
dass das Game in einem scheiß Zustand ist.
What the fuck.
Und dann, oh ja, es gibt einen Warte-Emote, super.
Das Spiel hat 85 Billionen dran, 78 Probleme.
Ja, was ihr alles tut.
Ihr tut ja nichts anscheinend.
So, wir kommen uns das letzte Video an.
Next.
Oh, man hört ihm richtig an,
dass er pissed ist.
Da war keine Ironie dabei, das meinen die Ernst.
Das gibt es so Leute.
Erleichtert.
Gibt es jemand, der wirklich
Spielerlebnis verwendet?
Und, oh, also
im normalen Sprachgebrauch.
Das Video ist immer noch zu leise.
Jetzt aber.
Ja, jetzt ist gut.
Echt, ist es heute leiser als sonst?
Nee, aber jetzt müsste okay sein.
Guck mal.
Das ist übrigens auch was, was mich immer stört,
dass die Leute das dann immer
abtun mit
scheiß Gehate, weil ich hab's so oft gesagt,
dass eigentlich die, die am meisten
haten, wünschen sich eigentlich gleichzeitig am
meisten, dass die Games Erfolg haben.
Natürlich Ausnahmen bestätigen
die Regel, aber wie viele Leute gibt
es, die beispielsweise seit,
nehmen wir mal World of Warcraft,
wie viele Leute gibt es seit World of Warcraft
seit Release-Spielen und da seit den letzten
5-6 Jahren permanent am Flamen drüber
sind. Das sind die Hardcore-Fans
der Hardcore-Fans.
Es ist, übrigens,
was ich auch gelesen hab, ist, dass verschiedene
Fähigkeiten auch total verbuggt sind.
Dass die überhaupt nicht das machen, was
man steht.
Erst mal schön,
erst mal schön geflamed.
Ja gut, das gibt's immer noch und ich glaube
auch echt, wenn man
ultra casual spielt, so
keine Ahnung, 1-2 Stunden
ab, wach, noch nicht mal am Tag,
was weiß ich, über ein paar Tage
verteilt, dann kann man wahrscheinlich
wirklich lang Spaß haben an dem Game.
Weil man dann nie einen Blick
unter die Haube machen muss.
Und bei New World ist halt beim Blick
so unter die Oberfläche
ist halt nie was, nirgendwo, egal
in welchem System.
Eine Sache, die mich persönlich bei New World
immer noch ein bisschen
abschreckt, jetzt so rein
vom Optischen,
dass die Welt und die
Charakter irgendwie nicht zusammenpassen.
Ich kann mir da
nicht helfen, aber
es sieht einfach nicht passend
aus.
Sehr schwer zu beschreiben,
ich kann das, wisst ihr was ich meine?
Ich kann das nicht anders erklären.
Normalerweise sehen Games
in irgendeiner Art und Weise,
wenn sie gut gemacht sind,
so gesamt optisch
stimmig aus. Das gilt
von Fortnite bis zu Breath
of the Wild, bis zu
World of Warcraft, bis zu ultra
fotorealistischen Dinger wie
Crysis, wie sonst was.
Aber die haben
irgendwie einen Grafikstil,
dass da ein
Gesamtbild rauskommt.
Und bei New World
finde ich, sieht die Welt aus,
sagt man mal, könnte schon aus
einem normalen MMO oder aus einem normalen
Fantasy-Game oder sowas sein.
Aber der restliche
Charakter-Style, das passt irgendwie überhaupt nicht
bei.
Gibt's öfters.
Jetzt ist doch irgendwie so, dass
keine Eisen findet, oder?
Hab ich auch irgendwo gelesen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich Absicht, weil alles, was höher ist, gar nicht richtig funktioniert.
Was sind MMOs, die schwierig sind?
Moment, da muss ich mal kurz was zu sagen.
13 Monate Leku, danke schön.
Sind MMOs, die schwierig
und komplex sind, Spiele sie zu gut
zu gestalten als Developer?
Gut, ich bin kein Spieleentwickler, ich kann da jetzt nicht
aus erster Hand dazu, also ich bin
zwar Entwickler, aber ich bin kein Spieleentwickler,
aus erster Hand nichts dazu zu sagen, aber ich würde schon
sagen, dass MMOs
vom Komplexitätsfaktor
habe ich dich übersehen.
Für alle, die ich jetzt übersehen habe.
Gut, Flo, danke schön für den Sub.
Ja, also ich würde schon sagen, dass MMOs
eines der komplexesten Sachen sind.
Generell, lassen wir mal aus
Multiplayer-Spiele mit
also generell Multiplayer-Spiele.
Zumal MMOs
ja noch die extremste Form von Multiplayer-Spiele sind.
Das ist da nicht nur irgendwie 32,
32, 64, 64, wie vielleicht mal Battlefield
und das ist schon komplex genug, gehe ich
mal ganz stark davon aus.
Aber natürlich auch ganz andere Anforderungen und
aber MMOs stelle ich mir als
ziemlich komplex vor.
Ich meine, im Kern,
so die Grundgedanken,
so die Grundgedanken
von jedem Online-Spiel sind ja
meistens relativ einfach.
Bei MMOs kannst du sagen, so Grundgedanken
mäßig, ok, du hast einen Client, du hast
einen Server, die musst du irgendwie heartbeat
mäßig miteinander sinken, du brauchst eine
Datenbank, wo das Date drinne gespeichert
wird und so. Das ist natürlich
in der Theorie, klingt das alles immer super
super simpel, aber im Detail
würde ich schon sagen, sind
MMOs mit die kompliziertesten
Sachen. Bei MMOs
spielt so viel mit rein,
du brauchst ja erstmal, selbst
wenn du, und das ist schon verdammt
schwierig für einen MMO, wenn du einen
guten technischen Unterbau hast, also du brauchst
einen guten, du brauchst eine gute Serverseite, du
brauchst eine gute Kleinseite, das muss
durchdacht gemacht sein zu dem Spiel passend
wie da wann, wie was gesunken wird,
es darf nicht zu viel, es darf nicht zu wenig sein
und
sodass es auch sicher ist, dass es keiner
exploiten kann und so. Selbst wenn du das
alles, also wenn du die Netzwerk
und Performance
und so die
Basics gut hinbekommen hast, kann dein
MMO immer noch scheiße sein,
weil das Spiel kacke ist.
Gut, das
gilt letztendlich für jedes Game, aber
bei MMOs kannst du so viel verkacken,
Zeitinvestment,
Klassen Balance, irgendwie
Fähigkeiten Balance,
Endgame Balance, irgendwas,
PvP, Monster Pass
Finding, alles möglich, du kannst so ultra
viel verkacken und
ich würde schon sagen, dass MMOs sowohl
vom Aufwand her, als
auch von der allgemeinen
Schwierigkeit her,
mit das Komplexeste
und Schwierigste sind, das du machen kannst.
Das würde
ich schon so sehen.
Final Fantasy 14 ist ein gutes
Beispiel für wie man es von einem verkackten Produkt
zu einem ganz guten Produkt
hinbekommt.
Final Fantasy 14
kam ja original raus, als Spiel, was glaube ich
nicht mehr als 20 Spieler oder so auf
dem gleichen Bildschirm zeigen konnte,
das wissen die meisten heute gar nicht mehr.
Ich glaube es waren 20 Spieler, also Max
oder 10 Spieler, es war
ein Witz für einen MMO am Anfang.
So, das Original
Final Fantasy 14 hat halt so gesagt,
dass sie das Spiel nochmal komplett überarbeitet haben,
die Hälfte der Map weggeschmissen haben,
ihr fake
rundenbasiertes System rausgeschmissen
haben, dann kam
A Realm Newborn,
hieß das glaube ich, und ab da
ging es eigentlich aufwärts, da hatten sie auch
einen neuen Director und alles, also bei einem MMO
ist es auch wichtig, dass du irgendeinen Typ da sitzen hast,
der Warnung hat von dem, was er macht.
Ja, aber die haben es hinbekommen.
Ja.
Ja, es gibt total viel,
es gibt total viel.
Also ich muss sagen,
in-Game,
in-Game, äh,
technisch was, ich muss kurz ein bisschen Musik anmachen,
wenn ich hier gerade am labern bin, also
in-Game markt technisch so,
was Crafting und
Preise und Drops
und so angeht, da muss man sagen, da hat das Path of Exile,
finde ich, eigentlich
dazu perfekt gemacht.
Path of Exile
hat halt, dadurch, dass du
Drops zum
verbessern der Items brauchst, hast du
automatisch quasi
ein System drin, was Currency
wieder vernichtet, was praktisch
ist, weil ansonsten hast du bei MMOs, die
sagen wir mal auf Gold und sowas passieren, das Problem,
dass die Leute Monster
killen, am Anfang ist ein Gold viel wert,
in einem Monat ist ein Gold wenig
und in einem Jahr ist ein Gold nichts.
Wisst ihr, wie ich mein, das wird
einfach immer nur mehr und das hat Path of Exile
finde ich nahezu perfekt gemacht.
BDO hat's
ein bisschen anders probiert,
3, so dankeschön für den Sub,
BDO hat's ein bisschen anders probiert, BDO
sagt, hey, wir geben einfach Preise
vor und reglementieren das mit so
einem Auktionshaus, dass du
nicht direkt an Spieler traden kannst.
Das ist genau das Gegenteil von dem, was
Path of Exile macht,
Path of Exile ist im Prinzip eigentlich
komplett offen, aber du verbrauchst
Currency zum Craften von Items.
Die haben das, finde ich, nahezu perfekt
gemacht.
Die Städte sehen ja auch alle gleich aus.
Ja, das ist wirklich
beeindruckend, dass Blizzard
World of Warcraft damals
so gut hinbekommen hat, allerdings
waren das auch
Ausnahmezustände
und die haben das
sehr clever gemacht damals bei World of Warcraft, die haben
sich Leute genommen,
es gab ja MMOs,
auch wenn manche Leute
behaupten, Blizzard hätte mit World of Warcraft
MMOs erfunden, das stimmt ja nicht,
aber die haben das sehr geschickt gemacht.
Die haben sich Leute gesucht, Jeff Kapler zum Beispiel,
der Overwatch, Papa Overwatch
Jeff,
der war ja früher Everquest
Rader, Top
Rader, da gab's ja auch
Flameposts von ihm, die waren sich die Leute
heute noch drüber lustig,
wo er gesagt hat, wie sehr das Game
suckt und sowas, also die haben sich damals Top
Leute geholt,
aus anderen Spielen, um
ihr Endgame zu designen und sowas, das war schon wirklich
schlau, dazu kam, dass das einfach
mit
World of Warcraft 3 eine super Grundlage
gab, sowohl was Lore angeht, als auch
was Fanbase angeht, das waren
besondere, also da standen wirklich
alle Sterne quasi so im richtigen Winkel
zueinander für World of Warcraft,
man muss aber sagen, an sich
ist das ja kein Hexenwerk, andere Spiele haben
das ja auch schon hingekriegt, guckt man sich
mal an, das allererste MMO so richtig,
was viele Mainstream-mäßig überhaupt
recognized haben,
war ja Ultima Online,
danach hast du so Sachen wie Everquest
gehabt oder später noch Dark Age of Camelot,
was immer noch für mich das beste PvP
Spiel aller Zeiten ist,
was ich gerade übrigens nebenbei ein bisschen auf
einem Free-Shot sinnlos im Kreis laufe,
was aber sehr langweilig ist und keiner
sehen will, aber das ist immer noch gut,
die haben das auch schon hinbekommen
und die haben das auch in relativ kurzer Zeit
damals entwickelt,
ich glaube Dark wurde in 2 Jahren oder 1,5 Jahren
oder so entwickelt, aber
natürlich muss man sagen,
die Zugänglichkeit von alten
MMOs war halt echt
grausam schlecht
versus neue
MMOs,
also tausend
Slash-Commandos, die du wissen musstest,
Interface, was kein Mensch bedienen kann
und dann kam irgendwann World of Warcraft,
man hat gesagt, okay, wir nehmen das jetzt
und machen da was wirklich Rundes draus,
World of Warcraft
im Release war das perfekte MMO,
ich hab das nie großartig gespielt muss ich sagen,
ich hab diesen World of Warcraft, natürlich hab ich ein bisschen gespielt,
aber ich war mit anderen MMOs beschäftigt
zur damaligen Zeit, zur damaligen Zeit galt
der World of Warcraft als Noob-MMO, weil
für die damalige Zeit weich
gespielt war, heute
sagen die Leute, Classic WoW so best ever,
aber ich muss sagen, Classic WoW
auch die ersten Addons, so
irgendwie weit ich's mitbekommen hab, waren mehr oder weniger
das perfekte MMO, du konntest das
du konntest das
gut einsteigen, es hatte aber
auch genug Tiefe für absolute Hardcore-Spieler,
die NoLive
247 spielen wollten.
Sowohl von der Geschichte her hat es viele
interessiert, vom Suchtfaktor
her, vom Item, von
Item Grand, dass es einfach was Neues war,
die übelsten Casuals, die keine Ahnung hatten,
konnten spielen, wie auch die super
spektakulierten High-End
E-Sports-Rate-Typen, das war
eigentlich insgesamt so mit das
perfekte Game.
Also für
für die MMOs der damaligen Zeit.
Das stimmt, ja.
Poggers Gift
weiß ich von wann, aber doch ich weiß
schon ein bisschen her.
So, jetzt gucken wir aber endlich mal das Video fertig.
Null, bevor ich hier ewig rumgeschwitzt hab.
Gleich erzählt er was New World alles
kleinzeitig macht.
Naja, New
World kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten,
ob das gut läuft. Die haben jetzt erstmal ungefähr
40% der Spieler verloren innerhalb
innerhalb
von 2 Wochen oder so.
Oder 3 Wochen.
Und ja, das ist normal, dass es
einen großen Spielertrop gibt, aber
40% in 3 Wochen ist schon
krass.
Na gut, nur weil es mal Games gab,
die 80% verloren haben, heißt es nicht, dass es
normal ist. Also, ey, es
mag normal sein, aber normal ist
auch, dass viele MMOs
quasi nach dem Release innerhalb der nächsten paar Monate
nahezu dead sind. Und das ist ja das,
was man vielleicht, wenn man New World spielt, nicht unbedingt
haben möchte.
Okay, wenn ich richtig verstand, Endgame ist schon mal
scuffed.
Er geht nicht.
Aber er ist kaputt.
Toll.
Ich weiß, man muss auch mal sagen,
guckt euch mal im Hintergrund an.
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist, ob das irgendein
Raid ist oder irgendeine Expedition oder irgendeinen
World Boss. Es sieht doch
schon, und das ist auch so eines meiner
Kritikpunkte, die schon direkt in der Beta zu nübeln
hat, er sieht schon ziemlich,
ähm, wie soll ich sagen,
repetiv ist das falsche Wort, das sind alle MMOs.
Brain-dead aus.
Guck mal, der drückt zwei Skills mehr,
kannst du ja in dem Spiel auch dann machen.
Der muss nix machen.
Boah, der macht zwei, der macht
drei, drei Spells.
Ivan, sieht das irgendwie spannend aus?
Ja.
Für pvp finde ich es schwer zu sagen, wie dysfunctional und kaputt das Spiel wirklich ist, aber ich werde mein Bestes hier machen.
In der Hintergrund ist jetzt ein Clip von der PvP-Experience, in der die Teams entscheiden, das Spiel zu exploiten.
Ich habe darüber gesprochen.
Du kannst, das ist das, was ich meine, du konntest easy as fuck, du konntest Area-Effects stacken, dann sieht das so aus.
... und es ist immer noch ein Ding.
Guck dich das mal an.
Was ist mit Amazon?
Null.
Einfach Area-Effects aufeinander, einfach aufeinander stellen oder e-Spam, easy.
I don't.
Ach ja, übrigens, was Amazon gemacht hat, meines Wissens nach, sie haben einfach ausgestellt, dass diese Effekte sich überlappen.
Was sie machen ist, naja, die spammen AE-Heal und AE-Damage auf einen Punkt, alles stirbt und alles ist dauerhaft geheilt.
Also muss ja diese komischen Flaggen hier captchern und die stellen sich einfach mit 30 Spielern hin und drücken eine Taste.
Und es ist nichts, was der Gegner tun kann.
Also big brain.
Und Amazon hat jetzt, soweit ich das mitbekommen habe, einfach ausgestellt, dass sich Area-Effects überlappen können.
Oder nee, das ist der letzte.
Ich glaube, dass der letzte Area-Effect immer gilt.
Das heißt, jetzt bringt stacken gar nichts mehr, was auch total bescheuert ist.
Eigentlich müssen Area-Effects gestackt werden, dass es immer weniger wird, keine Ahnung, du machst ein Heal auf den Boden, der heilt 100%, der nächste Heal dabei bringt 80% dabei, der nächste Heal dabei bringt 60%, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung müsstest du das eigentlich machen, sodass es sich quasi, sag mal so, ab 10 Heals quasi nicht mehr lohnt.
Aber die hatten entweder full stack, alles bringt 100% oder nichts.
Guck dir das an.
Guck dir das an, das ist so dumm, das ist so dumm, dass man allein schon daran nicht gedacht hat im Vorfeld.
Guck, das ist so dumm.
Guck mal, die machen nichts, die stehen einfach an der Flagge und drücken einen Knopf.
Das ist so dumm, das ist so dumm.
Guck, und die Gegner machen ja das Gleiche, die stehen alle an der Fahne, das sind die Gegner, die stehen alle an der Fahne und jeder drückt einfach nur einen Spell.
Das ist so hängen geblieben.
Das ist auch geil, ein Unverwundbarkeits-Klitsch.
Aber da muss ich sagen, das gab es in MMOs früher auch schon, ich kann mich in Dark noch dran erinnern, da haben Leute wirklich Fenster getrackt.
Ich muss sagen, was ist denn heute los, wieder halb am abkratzen.
Ich auch in Dark damals, und in Dark war es sogar noch so schlimm, du konntest damit sogar auf Sachen raufklitschen, wo du nicht raufklitschen solltest.
Aber seitdem haben das MMOs eigentlich in Griff bekommen, ihr müsst euch das mal angucken, das ist jetzt echt der Wahnsinn.
Das ist ein Problem, dass das, das ist aber so Bewegungsabgleich irgendwie, also dass das kleinzeitig ist, aber das muss natürlich serverseitig auf Sync getestet werden.
Das Problem dabei ist, dass die Typen unverwundbar sind, was übrigens mittlerweile glaube ich gefixt ist, übrigens weil, wisst ihr wie die das gefixt haben, wisst ihr wie Amazon diesen Klitsch, passt mal auf, das muss ich jetzt sagen, wisst ihr wie Amazon diesen Klitsch gefixt hat, diesen Unverwundbarkeits-Klitsch.
Die haben jetzt ne Exception oder sowas eingebaut, dass sobald du dein Fenster bewegst, stürzt das Game ab.
Setz keinen Witz, sobald du dein Fenster im Winners-Modus bewegst, stürzt das Game ab.
Das ist der Fix von Amazon.
Ja, aber was ich sagen wollte ist, das ist gar kein Problem, dass das, dass man irgendwie, dass die Connection quasi abreißt und dann irgendwie ein Spieler in der Luft hängt oder so, das hat man in jedem MMO schon gesehen.
Problematisch ist, wenn dieser Spieler dann nicht mehr damagebar ist.
Also normalerweise ist es ja so, wenn du Link-Dead oder wie auch immer man das in dem Game nennt gehst, dann hängst du halt, dann kriegt dein Client, sendet dein Client keine Stats mehr, dein Client verarbeitet keine neuen Updates mehr, aber du selbst bist halt auf dem Server bewegungslos an dieser Position.
Das heißt, wenn dich ein Gegner angreift, dann kann er dich einfach killen, ohne dass du was machen kannst, weil du bist ja quasi, dein Spiel ist ja gecrashed.
Muss das auch sein? Auf dem Server lebst du noch, aber es gibt keine Inputs mehr.
Ja, das Problem ist, wenn du disablest, wenn du disablest, hast du da nichts mehr übrig in dem Game.
Was ist eigentlich aus Anthem 2.0 geworden?
Das ist nicht gebrochen.
Ihr fasst alles anscheinend.
Was ist garbage? Ich hab's nicht verstanden. Was ist garbage? Die Spieler? Was hat er gesagt? Ist das ein Raid oder ein Dungeon? Ich glaube, warte mal. Alter, was ist denn heute los?
Die Community ist garbage. Ich vermute mal, dass das irgendein World Boss ist oder sowas, aber ich bin mir da ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher. Keine Ahnung.
Ah, die Community.
Na ja.
Bist du Max FPS? Was? Ich weiß gar nicht, wie kommst du da drauf?
Also ich wusste einmal eine Sache noch zu sagen.
Also es kommt natürlich auch ein bisschen auf das Game an, aber es ist eigentlich nahezu in jedem MMO so, zumindest in MMOs mit PvP oder zumindest in MMOs, die jetzt nicht Singleplayer sind, so wie Elder Scrolls Online oder so,
wo du mit besonders viel Zeit auf Wand und nennen wir es mal besonders hoher Game-Knowledge und vielen Spielern in Kombination,
ihr Vorteile erarbeiten kannst, dann ist es eigentlich immer so, dass irgendwelche komischen Möchtegern-Elite-Guilden, den jeweiligen Server oder was auch immer, dominieren.
Das ist eigentlich mehr oder weniger normal. Es ist halt die Frage, inwieweit das Game das noch zusätzlich fördert oder nicht.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was er dazu zu sagen hat. Es ist in Dark auch so gewesen. Das muss ich halt immer als Beispiel bringen, weil ich das Jahrzehnte gefüllt gespielt habe und du hattest da auch sehr viele Möchtegern-Elite-Leute.
Das kann man ganz schwierig beschreiben. Kennt ihr so Möchtegern-Elite-Leute in MMOs? Das ist so eine ganz spezielle Gruppe von Leuten. Das ist sehr schwierig zu beschreiben.
Da wird im Prinzip auch exploitet, was zu exploiten ist, wenn das irgendwie möglich ist. Ich hab das ja früher selbst gemacht.
Da wird nicht nur exploitet, da wird auch quasi alles andere gegrieft, was sein muss. Ich erinnere mich zum Beispiel noch daran, dass als ich Dark gespielt habe,
auf meinem alten Server, da ist jemand bei einem Verkehrsunfall gestorben und dann hat man gesagt, also die Gilde damals von dem, hat gesagt,
wir machen quasi im Grenzgebiet, und Dark war ja ein PvP Spiel, dann hatten sich quasi alle drei reiche Realms getroffen im PvP-Gebiet und haben quasi die letzte Ehre erwiesen.
Das war ein relativ bekannter Spieler damals. Da sind dann aus allen drei Reichen die Leute hin und haben sich halt friedlich zusammen im Kreis hingesetzt.
Es war auch GM dabei, das war eigentlich ganz cool gemacht. Allerdings hattest du wieder so Möchtegern-Super-Elite-Typen am Start,
die dann von der Seite reingerusht sind und angefangen haben, die Leute zu killen. Ja, das Game erlaubt das.
Das Game erlaubt das, aber das ist trotzdem nicht die feine Art. Ich meine, Real Life erlaubt auch vieles, um nicht zu sagen alles.
Also rein physikalisch, aber erlaubt ist es nicht und tut das oftmals so gut im Grund. So, die sind dann reingerusht,
sondern danach gab es, jetzt mal zu erklären, was ich mit Möchtegern-Elite-Leute meine. Wir waren damals, muss man dazu sagen,
ich weiß, MMO-Schwanzvergleich, wir waren zumindest auf dem damaligen Sommer mit die beste Achtergruppe, zumindest in unserem Realm.
Wir haben bei dem Scheiß halt mitgemacht, wie man das macht, man hat sich hingesetzt, hat keinen Scheiß gebaut.
Und du hattest allerdings auf der anderen Seite Leute, die auch permanent im Forum immer den Dicken gemacht haben.
Und das waren halt auch die gleichen Leute, die dann damals diese Zeremonie, nenne ich es jetzt mal, gestört haben.
Und danach im Forum, Riesendiskussion, Riesendiskussion, und da kamen die Leute dann an und meinten allen Ernstes,
und da sieht man mal, was das für abscheuliche Leute sind, die haben dann ernsthaft geschrieben im Forum damals,
kann ich mir auch richtig dran erinnern, ja, was stört ihr denn auch mein Spiel mit so einer Aktion?
Also aus der Sicht dieser Leute hat man ihr Spiel zerstört durch quasi so eine Trauerfeier im Grenzgebiet.
Die sind so durch gewesen und es gibt so möchtegern Elite-Leute, die gibt es leider oft in MMOs
und halt leider auch oftmals in der Konzentration zusammen in so möchtegern Elite-Guilden.
Und das hast du da wahrscheinlich auch. Und das ist halt auch ein Spiel, was das irgendwie anzieht.
Oh nein.
Was? Die Leute sind da komplett durch. Die sind da komplett durch.
Die sind da komplett durch.
Durch.
Übrigens dazu muss man sagen, also meiner Eindruck nach, so diese möchtegern Elite-Leute in MMOs,
die dann auch auf diesem Level agieren, die posten das zum Schocken und zum Provozieren.
Gar nicht mal, weil die das irgendwie aus innerer Einstellung her vielleicht geil finden oder so.
Die wollen einfach nur, sagen wir so, Aufmerksamkeit und Schocken und zeigen, wie überlegen sie sich fühlen.
Das ist das, worum es bei dieser ganzen Geschichte geht. Und da hast du halt gerade in Top-Guilden immer wieder
so paar spezielle Individuen, gerade in MMOs.
Warum Wupplos? Ganz einfach. Weil ich den Account erstellt habe, bevor ich überhaupt selbst wusste, dass ich streamen will.
Was ist los? Das konnte ich ihm nicht folgen.
Ja, das sehe ich auch so.
Das ist das, was ich eben erzählt habe. Du kannst einfach Leute, wenn du quasi sagst, hey, keine Ahnung,
stell euch vor, ihr seid mit unseren Leuten auf dem Discord und sagt, Alter, den Typ muss man bannen.
Und es reporten einfach 100 Leute aus eurer Gilde einen Typ, dann wird er gebannen für 24 Stunden.
Weil Amazon so ein automatisches Reporting-System hat. Ob der was gemacht hat oder nicht, ist vollkommen egal.
Der wird einfach gebannen. Du kannst den bannen zwar appealen, aber das appealen dauert länger als der eigentliche bannen.
Weil Amazon nicht hinterherkommt. Das ist richtig fake. Ach ja, und die Leute, die das abüsen und banns reporten,
die werden natürlich auch nicht sanktioniert, weil das kannst du ja nicht machen. Sobald du Leute, die reportest, sanktioniert, reportet ja niemand mehr.
Das automatische System ist das Problem.
Und das appealen dauert mehr als 24 Stunden. Du wirst einfach bannet werden, für das, was die größere Gruppe von Dipshits denkt, du bannst.
Es ist ein Verlust. Das Spiel ist ein Verlust. Das Bauen ist ein Verlust. Das PvE ist halb gebrochen.
Und durch gebrochen meine ich, dass es wirklich nicht funktioniert, einen großen Schuss von Content zu blockieren, das tatsächlich existiert.
Also, es ist sogar noch schlimmer, wenn du darüber nachdenkst. Das PvP ist gebrochen, komplett zerstört von Ausgaben und Bögen.
Die Kontrolle des Klienten macht es unglaublich einfach zu zerstören. Die Leute bannen sich für alles unter der Sonne.
Und fast nichts davon ist legitim. Die Kalkulationen sind gebrochen. Und wenn du ein weiteres Beispiel dafür brauchst, was dieses Spiel ist, ist es im Hintergrund.
Das ist der Zustand der neuen Welt. Du kannst nicht Portals oder Expeditionen machen. Ich meine, du kannst es sehr oft, aber es ist wirklich unglaublich schwer, jemanden zu bekommen, der einen von diesen Orben hat, und dann geht es los.
Es kann nicht wirklich gemacht werden, wie es sein soll. Die Kriege sind gebrochen, die Wirtschaft ist gebrochen.
Also, was machen die Leute? Sie spammen die Weltbosse, in denen man frantisch versucht, Kassaden zu bekommen oder einen Schuss auf den Bosse zu schlagen.
Als du die Kontrolle des Klienten machst, gibt es keine Skills, keine wirkliche Satisfaktion, und du machst alles, um in Sekundärsystemen teilzunehmen, in denen du es bekommst.
Der neue Welt ist ein gebrochenes Spiel, an diesem bestimmten Zeitpunkt. Es ist ein Spaß für eine Weile, und wenn du es in der meisten casualen Art spielen möchtest, klar.
Aber ich habe entschieden, dass ich heute den Kanal benutzen werde, um mich selbst zu fühlen.
Denn ich wollte dieses Spiel wirklich großartig sein. Ich wollte dieses Spiel wirklich als mein Haupttitel genießen, für Wochen, Monate, sogar Jahre, hoffentlich.
Und was es jetzt ist, schmerzt. Es schmerzt wirklich schlimm. Wie machen sie es?
Aber ich sage es nur ungern. Ich muss es von Anfang an.
Es schmerzt wirklich.
Also, ich habe ja auch so einen Schalter. Ich habe hier zum Beispiel so ein Zigbee.
So ein Teil.
Und da kannst du total viel mit abbilden. Du kannst Single Press machen. Du hast sechs verschiedene Buttons für Single Press.
Du kannst Single Press machen, Double Press, Triple Press,
Hold.
Also, du kannst allein schon pro Button vier verschiedene Funktionen
abbilden, vier verschiedene Funktionen abbilden, aber trotzdem muss man sagen,
damit jetzt beispielsweise so eine
dimmbare Lampe zu steuern, ist nicht so schön. Ich meine, klar, du könntest sagen,
an niedrigster Stufe, nächste Stufe, sowieso, aber da ist sowas zum Drehen schon nicht verkehrt.
Double Hold, ja, das ist das nächste Modus. Double Hold, wie auch immer. Wann entscheidet man, wann das zweite Hold anfängt?
Ich glaube, das ist... Ah, jetzt, das war der Sellout. Das war der Sellout. Der Sellout ist jetzt vorbei.
Das ist übrigens so eine, die gleiche Kamera, die ich auch im Flur habe, die habe ich mir mal in einem New 5er-Pack oder so bei Amazon Com bestellt,
dass sich das gelohnt hat. Die neuen kann man leider nicht mehr custom-flashen und deswegen sind sie nicht los.
Ist das ein Mass Effect?
Ist das ein Mass Effect-T-Shirt? Was? Was? Ein... Seriously? Ein Smarters Seifenspender?
Was? Was? Ein... Seriously? Ein Smarters Seifenspender?
Das Ding macht einen äußerst unergonomischen Eindruck, muss ich sagen. Du kannst ja deine Hand gar nicht richtig drunter halten, weil, guck mal, du kannst deine Hand nur hier drunter halten,
weil normalerweise müsste das ja so... Naja. Was ist denn, wenn dein Internet ausfällt? Kriegst du da noch Seife?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Ich mach mir garantiert kein Amazon Echo-Dings hier so an die Wand. Ich hab ein Amazon Fire Tablet und das hab ich als Dashboard an der Wand, aber auch mit eigenen Sachen und nicht mit Amazon drauf.
Ich kann dual-Purpose als Smart-Home-Control-Interface und als Elektronik-Art-Frame machen.
Dieser hat ein paar Extra-Features, die ihn ein bisschen besser machen als die anderen.
Und der erste ist der Smart-Home-Control-Widget.
Auch doch kein Mensch. Geh mal fort, kommt da noch irgendwas Gescheites?
Aber das ist nur Amazon-Shit, oder? Scama-Sohn.
Da fährt ernsthaft so ein Ding durch meine Wohnung mit einer Kamera und filmt alles.
Das kann sich dann Bezos angucken, wenn er ins Weltraum fliegt, oder was?
Nee, nee. Also ihr wisst, ich bin sehr aufgeschlossen was Smart-Home-Sachen angeht und ich bastel da seit Jahren dran rum.
Aber es gibt auch irgendwie Dinge, die muss ich mir nicht ins Haus stellen.
Verstehst du die Leute, die ein iPad Pro an die Wand hängen, ist doch mega, weißt du? Nee, verstehe ich nicht.
iPads eignen sich nicht wirklich als Home-Automation-Dashboards an der Wand. Das sind Android-Geräte deutlich besser.
Man kann Astro anwenden, um Event-Events zu investieren, oder Patrouillen durch dein Zuhause auszuwenden. Und sie können Geräusche triggern, wie Hunde, Barsche oder Siren.
Was für ein Schwachsinn. Wer hat denn das Bier da reingestellt überhaupt? Die Frau in der Küche oder was?
Obrey, wir sind ja divers, sorry, vielleicht der Mann in der Küche und bringen sie ihn jetzt aufs Sofa.
Ach nee, Moment, die Frau, sorry, falsch rum. Die Frau sitzt auf dem Sofa und der Mann hat sie in der Küche reingestellt.
Gebatet.
Also, na, nee, nicht wirklich. Mal ganz davon abgesehen, das Problem ist bei solchen Dingern, das funktioniert ja nur in Wohnungen, die so aussehen wie das, was sich Amazon denkt.
Bei mir würde der beispielsweise schon sofort an irgendeinem USB-Kabel hängen bleiben, was irgendwo runterhängt oder so.
Die haben immer so super geleckte, stylische Wohnungen in diesen Spots, so wie kaum eine Wohnung in echt eben aussieht.
Ich meine, die hat sogar, da siehst du mal, wie komponiert dieser Shot wieder ist, die hat sogar Schuhe an, guck mal, die hat sogar Schuhe an, die farblich zu den Sachen im Hintergrund passen.
Kokona-Switch, kriegst du bei uns so nicht an die Wand?
Typischer Kokona-Switch.
Sollen die Barfuß? Nee, einfach Socken. Ich hab nie Hausschuhe an, ich hab immer Socken an.
Bro, nicht einfach, das ist nicht einfach nur ein Water-Sensor, das ist der Water-Sensor.
Das ist übrigens, jetzt mal ganz im Ernst, das ist wirklich sinnvoll. Ich hab auch im Keller, nee sowas, was auch immer das hier ist, das hab ich nicht.
Ich hab auch im Keller zwei Stück Leak Detection, weil einmal, als es richtig geregnet hat, hätte er da vorne ein Video machen sollen.
Ich hab da vorne, ich hab da vorne ein Video. Das wüsste ich tatsächlich mal raus, ich hab da vorne ein Video.
Ich hab mal, als es richtig, richtig krass geregnet hat draußen, hab ich im Erdgeschoss gestanden und da war es ganz, es war leise im Haus und ich dachte mir, irgendwie plätschert es im Keller.
Und da bin ich im Keller runter und da ist aus dem Loch in der Wand einfach ein Wasserstrahl rausgekommen. Einfach so. Loch in der Wand, da kam ein Wasserstrahl raus.
So ungefähr, fast 30 Zentimeter in den Raum rein. Einfach ein Wasserstrahl aus der Wand. Da war ein Loch in der Wand, da kam ein Wasserstrahl raus.
Gut, es war nicht so viel, es ist dann wieder abgelaufen, aber das hat sich halt einfach gestaut draußen. Wir haben, muss dazu sagen, vor dem Haus ist, an dieser Ecke ist, ist aufgefüllt mit so Kies.
So Kies aufgefüllt, also da geht es ein bisschen da unten und das ist wahrscheinlich einfach voll gelaufen, weil es so krass geregnet hat.
Und die Kellerwand ist halt schon alt da, immer ganz dicht, da kam halt einfach ein Wasserstrahl aus der Wand.
So, und seitdem ich das mal hatte, habe ich zwei Wasserleak-Detektor-Sensoren unten hingelegt.
Was ist das, worüber schließt man den an? Das müssen wir uns jetzt mal kurz angucken, das finde ich tatsächlich ganz interessant.
Wie heißt die, Aotech Leak Sensor, Water Leak Sensor, ne, das ist der nicht. Hat er das verlinkt, das Zeug? Water, ok, ok, hier ist es doch. Sea Wave, passt sogar.
Water Sensor 7 Pro, Blood Sensor, Leak Sensor, Safety Sensor, Kastenfirmer, dafür braucht man keine Kastenfirmer.
Das finde ich tatsächlich sehr, sehr sinnvoll, ja. Kost, Kost, gleich her, 44,99, das geht sogar.
Das ist durchaus ok, hat Amazon das Teil mittlerweile?
Ne, das ist Gu Do Kuih, China-Chinesen-Zeug. Control Your Home, das ist bestimmt eine Kokona-Seite. Bei eBay.
Kastenfirmer auf den Seifenspender. Sea Wave, na das passt bei mir, ich habe relativ viel Sea Wave anscheinend. Ich glaube den kaufe ich mir.
Was ist denn ein Leakage? Gewichtsverlust durch verdunsten oder aussickern. Wie spricht man das aus? Leakage.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass dieses Wort existiert. Leakage.
Handsome für Leak, oder für Loch, Loch wo es ausläuft. Alter die Musik, WTF. Überwacht hier in relativ Luft.
Das bestelle ich mir nachher. Das bestelle ich mir nachher. Vielleicht, also nicht bei dem Shop, aber das bestelle ich mir nachher.
Was sollten wir angucken? Das Problem mit USB-C hat vorher einer geschrieben. Aber warum? USB-C ist perfekt, sagt man ja auch nicht. USB ist weit davon entfernt perfekt zu sein, vor allem das USB-Forum.
Ich meine es ist ja die Frage, ob was wir meinen. USB 3.0, 3.1, 3.2 oder vielleicht sogar 3.2, Gen 1, Gen 2, 2x2 oder was auch immer. Das weiß man ja nicht so genau.
Wobei 3.0 und 3.1 gibt es ja nicht mehr. Der Fibaro Fluid Sensor sieht besser aus, ja. Aber ich glaube anwendungstechnisch ist das EOTech Ding besser.
WTF.
Der Apple wird dann irgendwas anderes machen. Ich meine Apple hat ja jetzt schon, ich glaube die neuen haben ja schon USB-C, aber ich bin mir sicher Apple schafft es in den nächsten 5 Jahren was eigenes zu machen.
Alter, das ist ja wieder so typisches deutsches Influencer Kram, da kriegst du ja Anfälle, das kannst du ja gar nicht in Ruhe angucken.
Die sind aber so mega hektisch alle.
Also erstmal zu USB-C. Was macht dieses Kabel oder anders gesagt dieser Anschluss so perfekt und warum sollte jedes Gerät alle Anschlüsse rausschmeißen und nur noch USB-C verwenden?
Sollte es überhaupt nicht. Sollte nicht jedes Gerät USB-C verwenden. Wozu?
Es ist dieser kleine schicke Anschluss der so ziemlich alles kann. Mit diesem Anschluss kann ich Daten in einen enormen Geschwindigkeit übertragen.
Serielle Schnittstelle beste. Alter. USB weg.
USB-C pro Sekunde im Vergleich dazu schafft USB-A gerade mal 10 oder Lightning gerade mal 0,48 Gigabits pro Sekunde. Ja und mit der Geschwindigkeit ist er nun wirklich jetzt nicht das Ding.
USB-C vor allem in Kombination halt auch mit sagen wir mal Thunderbolt oder USB 4 ist wirklich nice. Also da sind wirklich viele coole Dinger dabei.
Ja zum Beispiel, dass du da quasi Pizzi Express sogar drüber machen kannst und sowas.
Ein USB-C Kabel kann enorm viel Strom liefern mit bis zu 100 Watt und das funktioniert alles parallel. 100 Watt über USB-C. Was ist denn das dann?
Wie ist denn das? 5 Ampere 20 Volt oder was machen die?
Ich mein mehr als 5 Ampere würde ich immer so diese kleinen USB-A nicht drüber machen. Wie setzen sich die 100 Watt zusammen?
Sind das 20 Volt 5 Ampere oder was?
Alles andere würde es auch keinen Sinn ergeben. Ich hatte ja schon mal die Ehre, vielleicht erinnert sich irgendjemand an das Weihnachts-LED-Video von vor einem Jahr, zwei Jahre.
Da hatten wir 5 Volt LEDs und ich hatte glaube ich einen 12 Ampere Netzteil dran. Und dann haben wir 5 Volt 12 Ampere gemacht über so Jumper-Kabel.
Und die Jumper-Kabel haben tatsächlich mehr oder weniger Monarch-S im Stream. Also kurz davor. Die waren kurz davor. Also lange hätte man das nicht betreiben sollen.
Also 12 Ampere über diese kleinen Putzkabel waren schon sportlich, sportlich auf jeden Fall. Deswegen von den USBs ist es auch nicht so eine dicke Kabel drin.
Der MacBook ist ja schon mal das erste Problem.
Oder schon nicht schlecht. Das liegt überhaupt nicht am Kabel, dass das möglich ist. Das Kabel ist da wirklich der kleinste Faktor dabei.
Warum ist MacBook das erste Problem? Weil Apple seit einer Weile der Meinung ist, keine Anschlüsse mehr an MacBooks dran machen zu müssen.
Das hat mit dem Kabel nichts zu tun. Das liegt daran, dass das USB-Forum und die Standardisierung einfach kommen.
Ich habe dazu auch mal ein Video gemacht.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels. USB 4 ist da und mein Hirn explodiert. Da erkläre ich das doch irgendwann zwischendurch. Ich zitiere mich jetzt mal kurz selbst.
Jetzt kommt es.
Ich finde es irgendwie eine bescheuerte Idee im Nachhinein seine Produkte umzubenennen. Aber wie gesagt, das USB-Forum macht das gerne.
Das ist der neue Name für das originale USB 3.
Also sprich auch auch übrigens genannt Super Speed USB mit 5 Gigabit pro Sekunde.
Also sprich, wenn ihr eine USB 3 Festplatte habt oder ein USB 3 Zubehör, dann würde sich das jetzt neuerdings USB 3.2 Gen 1 nennen.
Dann gibt es als nächstes, das ist das ehemalige USB 3.1, USB 3.2 Gen 2, 10 Gigabit die Sekunde.
Soweit, so gut, noch halbwegs nachvollziehbar. Man würde jetzt vielleicht erwarten, dass Generation 3 als nächstes kommt oder vielleicht sogar gleich USB 4.
Aber nicht mit dem USB-Forum. Die brauchen dann noch mal ne extra Wurst und zwar das richtige USB 3.2.
Jetzt kommt es.
Wie gesagt, die anderen USB 3.2, die ich euch vorher erzählt hab, sind ja eigentlich plus 3.0 und 3.1, unbenannt in 3.2. Das richtige USB 3.2 nennt sich eigentlich USB 3.2 Generation 2 mal 2.
Auch genannt Super Speed USB 20 Gigabit.
Tja, wer sich jetzt fragt, was mit dem los ist, das kann ich euch leider auch nicht beantworten.
Das ist das eigentliche Problem. Das ist das eigentliche Problem, dass der Scheiß von dem Chemium so unglaublich undurchsichtig ist.
Allerdings kann ich euch erklären, woher die mal 2 kommen. Die mal 2, also Generation 2 mal 2.
Ach ja, was meint ihr? Was meint ihr denn, woher die 2 mal 2 kommen, Leute? Woher kommen die 2 mal 2?
Das ist die unintuitivste Beschreibung aller Zeiten 2 mal 2. Die 2 mal 2 kommt daher, weil es zwei Datenleitungen sind.
Wer um alles in der Welt hat es gedacht, der Kunde interessiert sich dafür und muss wissen, wie viele Datenleitungen da drin sind.
Bezieht sich darauf, dass es zwei, nicht etwa, weil es doppelt so schnell ist, ja.
Okay, jetzt hab ich mein eigenes Video geleakt.
Die nächste Generation ist oder so, das wäre auch zu logisch. Nein, die mal 2 beziehen sich darauf, dass es jetzt zwei Datenleitungen im USB-Kabel gibt.
Das ist krunker, kranker, kranker I.O.
Anscheinend denkt sich das USB-Forum, es interessiert den Endkunde in irgendeiner Art und Weise, wie viele Datenleitungen in so einem USB-Kabel da drin sind.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr schon mal einen Endkunde oder Konsument habt, der irgendwie euch gefragt hat, ja sagen sie mal, also wie viele Datenleitungen sind eigentlich im USB-Forum?
Das interessiert die Leute nicht. Ich glaube, das kommt so gut wie nie vor.
Ja gut, sei es drum, so ist es halt, so heißt der Kram jetzt halt, ich kann nichts dran ändern, das USB-Forum hat das so entschieden und die dürfen das entscheiden.
So und jetzt gibt es USB 4. Genau und jetzt wird die ganze Sache noch verwirrender.
USB 4 ist, kann man sich glücklicherweise ganz gut merken, USB 4 hat eine Geschwindigkeit von bis zu 40 Gigabit.
Das ist eine schöne Kombination, USB 4, 40 Gigabit kann man sich merken und USB 4 hat auch schöne viele gute Neuerungen, ja.
Eigentlich ist fast alles gut an USB 4. Außer die Benahmung.
Außer die Benahmung wird nicht unbedingt besser und die Verwirrung bei manchen Endkunden oder generell nicht bei Endkunden, also bei allen eigentlich, wird auch nicht gerade weniger werden durch USB 4.
An sich hat USB 4 jede Menge gute Sachen, zum Beispiel, es ist zum Glück weiterhin ein USB-C Stecker, also sprich es gibt Gott sei Dank keinen neuen Connector, keinen neuen Stecker.
USB 4 ist kompatibel zu... Alter Max, Max komm mal zum Punkt. Man erkauft sich das zwar durch unglaubliche Komplexität an manchen Stellen, aber du kannst in USB 4 alles einstecken, was es vorher auch schon gegeben hat.
Das ist auch ein richtig großer Pluspunkt und ein weiterer Pluspunkt ist, dass USB 4 endlich oder eigentlich nur ein bisschen anderes Thunderbolt 3 ist.
Thunderbolt ist quasi das Intel-USB, wofür man eigentlich Lizenzen bezahlen musste als Hardware-Hersteller.
Also sprich, wenn man als Hardware-Hersteller gesagt hat, ey Intel, Leute, ich möchte Thunderbolt 3 implementieren, musstest du Lizenzgebühr an Intel bezahlen.
Und Intel hat das Ganze jetzt freigegeben, also sprich das ist ein netter Schachzug von Intel, hat das Ganze freigegeben, hat gesagt, ey Jungs, alter, lass mal USB und Thunderbolt.
Eigentlich wollte ich euch jetzt nur noch erklären, wie das jetzt mit USB 4 wird, weil die ganze Sache noch verwirrender wird.
Wieder zusammenführen, deswegen ist USB 4 implementiert, wird Thunderbolt 3 und USB 4 noch eine gewisse Weile der Anschluss der Wahl wieder werden.
So, wie gesagt, USB 4 ist bis zu 40 Gigabit schnell.
Die machen hier den Provider-Trick, bis zu 40 Gigabit.
Vielleicht habt ihr das rausgehört, denn eigentlich ist die korrekte Bezeichnung für USB 4, also für das schnelle USB 4, USB 4 Gen 3 x 2.
Also es ist die Generation 3 x 2 Datenleitung, was auf wie auch Gen 4 3 x 2, wie das berechnet wird, aber auf 40 mögliche 40 Gigabit kommt.
Um die Sache jetzt allerdings nicht so einfach zu machen, haben die sich überlegt, man muss keine 40 Gigabit unterstützen, um USB 4 draufschreiben zu können.
Um USB 4 draufschreiben zu können reicht es, wenn man USB 3.2 Generation 2 x 2 unterstützt, also auch genannt Super Speed USB mit 20 Gigabit.
Es macht es natürlich nicht unbedingt klarer, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel einen Kabel, oder ich frage mich, wie das wird, ehrlich gesagt.
Wenn ich mir jetzt einen Kabel, wenn ich jetzt einen Kabel suche, ja, wenn ich als Endkunde sage, hey, ich habe hier eine externe SSD, ich möchte die so schnell wie möglich anschließen, dann brauche ich einen Kabel mit USB C.
So viel ist klar. Allerdings schafft dieses Kabel dann 20 Gigabit oder schafft dieses Kabel dann 40 Gigabit.
Ich meine, da steht USB 4 drauf, ja. Da bin ich mal gespannt, wie sie das Ganze machen, ehrlich gesagt.
Und mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn die Verwirrung nicht noch weiter zunehmen würde.
Ja, also das ist das eigentliche Problem bei USB.
Dass das Gremium nicht in der Lage ist, ordentlich zu standardisieren und dass sie das Schlimmste machen, was du eigentlich bei einem Standard machen kannst, quasi retroaktiv alte Namen umbenennen.
Eigentlich sind Standards ja dafür da, dass du dich darauf verlassen kannst, ja.
Aber wenn du anfängst, drei Jahre später was Altes umzubenennen, ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn. Das machen die halt.
So und jetzt können wir uns das andere Video fertig angucken, was er uns zum Stecker erzählt.
Datenrate und Protokolle. Vor ein paar Tagen habe ich mein MacBook aufladen wollen und habe irgendwann gemerkt, dass er sich entlädt, anstatt sich aufzulehnt, obwohl das Kabel drinne steckte.
Also was habe ich getan? Adapter gewechselt, Steckdose gewechselt, PRAM und SMC vom Mac resettet, nichts. Bis ich dann irgendwann sensiert habe, dass ich nicht das Kabel genommen habe, sondern irgendein USB-C Kabel aus dem Rucksack.
Dieses Kabel, was genau? Typisch der Apple User halt wieder.
Genau so aussieht wie dieses Kabel, schafft maximal 65 Watt, wohingegen das hier 100 Watt schafft.
Das Kabelproblem ging dann so weit, dass ich eine Zeit lang dachte, mein Handy wäre defekt. Hier ist es nämlich so, dass ein Pixel 5 nicht mit einem OnePlus 8 Kabel geladen werden kann. Gar nicht.
Das ist aber nicht das Problem von USB-C.
Nicht mit einem anderen Adapter.
Das ist das Problem, was ich gerade gesagt habe, dass das gleiche drauf steht, aber es nicht klar ist, was es eigentlich genau ist.
Wohingegen das Huawei P40 Pro problemlos kann. Und ein anderes Beispiel, diese Mini-
Um die ganze Sache übrigens noch komplexer zu machen, mittlerweile hat Intel auch eingesehen, dass das USB-Forum absolut unfähig ist für USB-Standards und macht jetzt ja nochmal einen neuen Thunderbolt.
Es gibt jetzt ja quasi das Intel Thunderbolt 4.
Intel hatte ja eigentlich keinen Bock mehr auf Thunderbolt und hat gesagt, USB Leute, macht das mal.
Und Intel hat sich aber gedacht, die sind jetzt zu unfähig, wir machen jetzt nochmal ein neues.
Die Kamera, die Insta360 Go mit einem verbauten USB-C Anschluss lässt sich nur dann aufladen, wenn man das mit einem USB-C zu USB-A Kabel verbindet.
Wie unfassbar.
Nö, das glaube ich nicht. Never.
Das liegt eher daran, was das für ein Kabel ist.
Wie dumm das Ganze ist, merkt man das.
Nee, das glaube ich nicht. Das ist der Kamera doch vollkommen egal.
...von dieser Kamera auf seinem Mac übertragen möchte.
Denn dann muss man die Kamera über ein USB-C zu USB-A Kabel zu einem USB-A zu USB-C Adapter an den Mac verbinden.
Was?
Gut, das mag jetzt aber eher am Controller liegen.
Das Ganze gilt aber auch bei der Geschwindigkeit für die Datenübertragung, denn wie gesagt, USB-C ist nicht gleich USB-C.
Das stimmt im Endeffekt. USB-C ist halt einfach nur der Stecker. Man muss halt gucken, was drauf steht.
Auf der anderen Seite, es ist natürlich nicht seine Schuld, und das ist das, was ich in meinem Video auch sagen wollte.
Du kannst es von einem normalen Anwender gar nicht erwarten, dass er da durchblickt.
Vergiss es. Ich habe es ja in meinem Video gesagt, das ist nicht möglich, da durchzublicken.
USB-C ist nur ein Anschluss, hinter dem auch Thunderbolt stecken kann, was wie gesagt bis zu 40 Gigabits pro Sekunde überträgt.
Oder auch USB 3.2, was...
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Oder USB 4 Gen 3 x 2.
20 Gigabits oder auch USB 3.1 Gen 2.
Nein, nein, das stimmt nicht. Das heißt nicht USB 3.1 Gen 2.
Genau, USB 3.2 Gen 2 x 1. Boah, Alter.
USB 3.1 oder auch USB 3.0, was dann nur noch 5 beispielsweise 10 Gigabits schafft.
Und im schlimmsten Fall steckt hinter diesem Anschluss ein popeliger 2.0 Anschluss aus der Steinzeit,
was mir kriege 4 Punkt... Nee, 0,48 Gigabits schafft.
Zudem unterstützt nicht jedes USB-C Kabel...
Ja gut, das liegt aber dann daran, was dein Control, also was du auf der anderen Seite hast.
Dem Kabel ist das ziemlich egal.
Also beziehungsweise dem USB-C Stecker ist das ziemlich egal.
Es ist aber wir. Ich gebe ihm recht, es ist unglaublich schwer.
... ein Smartphonebild ans Fernseher zu übertragen.
Und der letzte Nachteil von USB-C hier in Bezug auf den Lightning Anschluss von Apple ist die Bauform.
Dadurch, dass ein Loch in der Mitte des Anschlusses ist, wird der Anschluss deutlich dicker und breiter.
Gleichzeitig aber auch instabiler.
Zudem kann sich hier in sehr viel Dreck ansammeln.
Aber gut, das sind Punkte, denen man getrost ignorieren kann in Anbetracht der ganzen Vorzeiten.
Man pustet einfach rein.
Welches Kabel nehme ich denn nun und woran erkenne ich das?
Richtige Kabel.
Kurz Antwort, gar nicht.
Online lese ich immer diese ganzen Weisheiten.
Nimm einfach das neueste Kabel oder nimm einfach das, was in Lieferung...
Man kann das, naja doch, man kann das insofern erkennen, wenn die Hersteller was ordentliches draufdrucken würden.
Aber das ist tatsächlich schwierig, ja.
... dabei war.
Naja, wenn ich immer für jedes Gerät das Kabel mitnehmen soll, was im Lieferumfang dabei war, hätte USB-C keinen wirklichen Sinn.
Und das neueste Kabel zu nehmen scheint auch nicht...
Aber man muss sagen, in der Regel funktioniert es einfach.
Bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo es halt nicht funktioniert, dann bist du am Suchen.
Aber zu 99% funktioniert es.
Nimmst USB-C-Kabel, stöpselst das dran und dann geht's.
... ist nie genau neu und ist trotzdem nicht für das...
Gerade wenn du aber solche Sachen machen willst mit bis zu 100 Watt Laden und sowas da, dann wird's natürlich ein bisschen schwieriger.
... mittlerweile so viele USB-C-Kabel in zu Hause rumliegen haben, ist der einzige Tipp, den ich euch...
... gut...
... willst du sagen.
Der übliche Wahnsinn.
Ach so, wir waren ja noch bei New Useful Smart Home Gear.
Was kommt denn da sonst noch?
Speaking of Z-Wave products, well, Z-Wave...
Das Video war etwas Payne's Champ.
... 0.3 Inches dick, plus, mit dem hohen Preis-Tag, ist das ziemlich nützlich für nicht viel.
Sie haben auch einen neuen, geschlossenen, geschlossenen, geschlossenen Sensor ausgeliefert, den ZS-E41.
Jetzt, dieser ist wieder sehr...
So... Soos!
Soos!
... teuer, plus, es hat...
Das ist... Das ist... Das ist... Soos... Das ist das wie die... Nicht Soos!
Nicht... Nicht... Nicht Soos! Ich würde eher sagen, Soys.
Die Amis sprechen Soys, das hat man ja auch gerade bei Gears of War Let's Plays und sowas gesehen.
Die sprechen das so Soos aus. Soos!
Auch kein Mensch.
Das braucht... Ganz ehrlich...
Ich... Für Fenstersensoren ist das beste, der billigste AliExpress-Fenster-Sensor.
Einfach weil du davon viele brauchst.
Euros? Moment, da ist gar kein Kokona?
Okay, ich hab nix gesagt.
Außer Dänen.
Dänen!
Dänen lügen nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, Moment, Logitech hat den Krempel aber mittlerweile eingestellt, ne?
Logitech hat's ja einfach gedacht...
Wie, ihr habt ne 500 Euro Fernbedienung gekauft?
Ist uns egal, wir stellen das einfach mal ein!
Ja.
Ja, wurde eingestellt.
Hast du gelitten?
Ja, ich bin gelitten.
Ich bin gelitten.
Es wird matter-kompatibel.
Und es wird die Devise lokalerweise kontrolliert, wo das sogar möglich ist.
Und es wird seine eigene Chargebase und einen IR-Extender haben.
Was ist das? Was ist...
Moment, du kannst Remount mit irgendeinem Motor, was ist das?
Was?
Da kannst du im Keller dann quasi dein...
Was auch immer, ich hab im Keller nicht so nen Schalter, aber man könnte...
...ein irgendwas auf- und zudrehen oder so.
Yo-Link!
Braucht kein Mensch!
Wozu?
Ich hab einfach mein Handy, wenn ich irgendwelche Sounds brauche oder Nachrichten.
Ich will die Zeug gar nicht mit Amazon integrieren.
Ich will mit meinem Zeug integrieren.
Alter, das sieht hässlich aus.
Das sieht aus wie ein Notfallknopf im Krankenhaus.
Oder so, oder irgendwie ein Rentner-Telefon mit Kurzwahl.
Das würde ich mir nicht daheim hinlegen.
Oh, sieht das scheiße aus.
Wie oft hat eigentlich Amazon schon gesagt in diesem Video?
Ich würde mal sagen, bestimmt 20 Mal.
Ja, die sind wirklich nicht schlecht, allerdings nicht die aktuelle Version.
Die V2, weiß ich nicht, ob man die flashen kann.
Nur die, die man custom-flashen kann, weil...
Da kann man nämlich das hier draufflaschen.
Und das ist Poggers.
Dann hat man ordentliche Firmen mit Web-Interface für die Kamera.
Also ja, ich hab auch meine Kamera geflasht.
Du weißt, bei mir wird alles geflasht.
Das sieht schon ein bisschen blöd aus.
Subscription? Ich will keine Subscription.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Ja, okay.
Und dann ist dein Internetzugang weg und nichts geht mehr.
Never sub, never donated Adblock on free entertainment. Genau.
Die haben ihre kompletten Kundendaten, by the way, geleakt.
Unter anderem Gewicht der Leute.
Also ich würde mir im Leben von denen nichts holen, was ich nicht irgendwie flashen kann.
Hier, Wise League. Das haben die Leute wahrscheinlich schon wieder komplett vergessen.
Und die haben unter anderem Gewicht.
Hier, Höhe, Gewicht, Gender, Bone Density, Bone Mass, Daily Protein.
Das hat noch deine Kacke analysiert wahrscheinlich.
Die haben alles geleakt, die haben alles geleakt, komplett.
Und die Videofeeds waren über den China-Chinesen-Server abrufbar.
Also das würde ich mir im Leben nicht in die Wohnung stellen.
Das haben die Leute schon wieder vergessen.
By the way, das ist doch ein Reskin von der Xiaomi Mi Scale, oder?
Das sieht original so aus, man.
Weil die habe ich bei mir im Bad.
Das ist doch einfach ein Reskin anderer Farbe.
Können wir nichts erzählen.
Wozu smarte Wagen?
Na, du kannst dein Gewicht automatisch protokollieren.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz nice.
Also ich habe ja auch so eine hier.
Und der schickt nach einem wiegewage Vorgang, schickt er per Bluetooth eine Message.
Und ich habe einen Controller, der die Message abgreift und bei mir den Home Assistant schreibt.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt so eine History.
Grafverlauf von wie pepo fett ich bin.
Hast du die geflasht? Nein, die ist nicht geflasht, aber die geht offline.
Ich habe die nie gepaart mit irgendeiner App oder sonst was.
Die schickt per Bluetooth einfach die Nachricht raus und fertig ist.
Reskin.
Bluetooth. Ja, genau, Bluetooth.
Was ist das für Big Brain Zeug? Moment.
Was ist das?
Ein Vorhangsauf und zumacher.
Tja, das wäre eine coole Sache, aber ich habe keine Vorhänge.
Und ich habe bei mir in der ganzen Wohnung keine Vorhänge.
Doch, stimmt nicht, im Bad habe ich einen.
Max lügt. Im Bad habe ich einen.
Ich habe aber Rolläden, die man teilweise steuern kann.
Aber coole Sachen. Switchbot macht coole Sachen.
Wisst ihr, was wirklich nice ist von Switchbot?
Der originale Switchbot, da habe ich auch welche.
Der originale Switchbot, der ist wirklich cool. Guckt euch das mal an.
Richtig Big Brain.
Ist das nicht poggers?
Der kann für dich Knöpfe drücken, die du nicht smart machen kannst.
Ach, er wieder hier.
Cool. Das ist richtig nice.
Das braucht man alles nicht dafür. Viel zu teuer.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was es gekostet hat. Guckt mal.
Das finde ich richtig cool. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was es gekostet hat.
Ich habe die mal gekauft, als es die kurzzeitig bei Amazon gegeben hat.
Das ist richtig nice, das Ding.
Also für alles, was du nicht smart machen kannst, ist der Switchbot wirklich poggers.
Was kostet der gerade mittlerweile?
Ich gucke mal kurz bei Amazon, was ich dafür bezahlt habe.
Ich sage es euch gleich.
Amazon. Amazon.
Amazon Orders.
Your Orders.
Switchbot.
So, Switchbot. Zwei Stück.
Zweier Set.
29 Euro habe ich dafür bezahlt.
Für einen anscheinend.
Das ist doch okay. Man braucht davon ja nicht viele.
Es gibt ja eh nicht viele Sachen, die man nicht automatisch...
Ach, guck mal da. Die China-Chinesen-Sachen sind natürlich wieder gleich viel günstiger.
Plutus Smart Fingerbot.
Der Fingerbot, alles klar. Warum nicht?
Aber die Idee finde ich wirklich sehr nice.
Ich muss immer stehen geblieben.
Wo ist das Video, Leute?
Habe ich das zugemacht?
Ah, ich kacke nur, ich habe es zugemacht.
Das geht, glaube ich, durch, oder?
Ja, NFC ist eh total unterschätzt.
NFC ist eines der besten Technologien, wenn du beispielsweise aufs Klo gehst und hast ein Handy dabei.
Und willst damit irgendwas triggern.
Überall, wo du dein Handy dabei hast, um etwas auszulösen, sind NFCs die billigsten Schalter.
Man kann sie auf oder auf ein Lichtswitch drücken.
Aber ich wollte ein bisschen Kontrollen mit diesen NFC-Tags.
Die gute Nachricht ist, dass die Switch-Bots uns neue Smart-Bulbs und eine neue Smart-LED-Strap bringen.
Was mich wirklich interessant an diesen Spezifikationen ist, dass sie Bluetooth und Wi-Fi sagen.
Das wäre ein bisschen eine Divergenz und könnte...
Man kann es nicht auf dem Handy triggern, weil du das Handy entweder entsperren oder auf dem Knopf drücken musst.
Es ist einfacher, das Handy beispielsweise abends neben das Bett zu legen.
Und es triggert ein alles Licht aus, anstatt dass du dann irgendwas drauf drücken musst.
Aber bei iPhones, weiß ich, bei Android geht das garantiert auch.
Du kannst dir mit Home Assistant auch so ein Widget machen, das scrollst du dann raus.
Also, dann musst du plus zweimal drücken oder so.
Aber einfacher als NFC-Tag halten ist natürlich noch einfacher.
Ne, Alexa meine ich.
NFC-Tags.
Home Assistant Amber finde ich unsinnig, brauchen wir nicht.
Brauchen wir auch nicht.
Brauchen wir alles nicht.
Schon wieder das Zettel-Corner-Steckdose.
Ne, ne.
Ja.
Wollen wir so eine Runde Battlefield 3 angucken?
Weißt du, ob ohne Programmer wieder möglichst 3er-Lampen zu flashen haben?
Das kommt drauf an, wenn du Glück hast und findest welche, die noch gehen.
Es gibt da keine Updates in der Zwischenzeit zu...
Das Problem dabei ist ja auch, dass die China-Hersteller mittlerweile anfangen,
ihre Produkte nicht mehr unbedingt mit ESPs auszustatten.
Und spätestens dann ist es mit Custom-Firmware vorbei.
Also viele der neuen China-Tuiya-Sachen sind halt keine ESPs mehr drin.
Und da kannst du es eh vergessen.
Leider, leider, es ist wirklich...
Eigentlich war das das Beste für Aus-allen-Welten.
Die Noobs konnten die App verwenden.
Die Leute, die keine Probleme mit der China-Cloud hatten, konnten es verwenden.
Und wir, sagen wir mal etwas anspruchsvollere User,
konnten den Kram flashen und damit machen, was sie wollten.
Aber ich habe vor 2 Wochen Steckdosen geflasht, das ging noch,
aber die waren auch schon ein bisschen älter.
Felix, danke für den Sub.
Schon die News vom Battle-Spiel?
Ja, habe ich, habe ich.
Habe ich mir schon angeguckt.
Ist ja nichts wirklich großartig Spannendes drin.
Gibt es einen Granatenindikator?
Es gibt ein paar neue Specialists.
Ja, dann kannst du...
Du mein, du könntest sie vielleicht aufschrauben,
aber Lampen kann man nicht gut aufschrauben.
Steckdosen schon, Lampen kannst du eigentlich eher vergessen.
Ist dann oftmals auch zugeklebt und sowas.
Wobei ich auch schon eine Steckdose hatte.
Da ging gar nichts.
Also das war ein ESP, aber man konnte sie nicht flashen.
Kein Cringe zum Abschluss.
Ich finde aber schon, dass sie das interessieren sollte,
weil die Leute, sagen wir so die Enthusiastenbenutzer,
kaufen den Kram ja letztendlich auch.
Und dann kaufen es weniger Leute.
Ich glaube, das lag weniger an den Herstellern,
sondern an den Resellern, dass sie das nicht wollten.
Tuya selbst dürfte das egal sein.
Ja, 5% war dann schlecht, oder?
Aber Tuya selbst dürfte das egal sein.
Die Reseller fanden das, glaube ich, kacke,
dass die Leute die Geräte verwenden konnten,
ohne quasi ihre Services zu verwenden.
Und deswegen haben die das, glaube ich, gemacht.
Ansonsten? Warum nicht?
5% mehr sind 5% mehr und hätte für sie ja keinen Unterschied gemacht.
Also macht ja keinen Sinn, es aktiv zu blocken.
Wenn man neue Chips verwendet und sagt,
man hat dadurch andere Vorteile, ja, dann wäre es mir auch egal.
Aber beispielsweise Firmware-Updates zu entwickeln,
die diese Sachen quasi ausbauen, die vorher möglich waren,
das macht ja keinen Sinn.
Das ist mehr Aufwand für den Hersteller
und bringt ihnen ja auch nichts.
Das haben die bestimmt auf Druck der Reseller gemacht,
vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Ja, und ergeblich geht das mittlerweile sogar offline.
Aber ich denke mal, du brauchst immer noch eine App zum Setup.
Müssen wir mal angucken.
Würde Sony oder Nintendo einen besseren PC bauen?
Ups, da habe ich irgendwas angeklickt, wollte ich gar nicht.
Fight in Go, voll was.
Nintendo garantiert nicht, Sony wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
PC ist halt eine sehr individuelle Geschichte.
Es gibt ja eh nicht den besseren PC.
Es gibt ganz gute Builds für den jeweiligen Einsatzzweck.
Und da bezweifle ich, dass Sony oder Nintendo
das irgendwie besser machen würden.
Guck mal, angeblich sieht das aus wie 4K.
Ja, das sieht eher aus wie 4K.
Ah, yes, Battlefield 3.
Ich überlege gerade, ob ich vorher noch das...
Was haben wir hier sonst noch?
Gratis Laptop plus...
Oh, was, letzte Preis.
Okay, da kommt mir doch erst mal das an.
Jo, Leute, und willkommen zu einem neuen Video.
Wurde mir vorgeschlagen, ich habe von ihm noch nie was gesehen,
hat auch nicht vieles gesagt.
Ich habe von ihm noch nie was gesehen, hat auch nicht vieles gesagt.
Was, letzte Preis.
Ich habe aber nie...
Legit noch, ich habe nie eBay-Kleinanzeigen benutzt.
Ich habe da immer einen riesen Bogen drum gemacht.
Verkaufen, sondern tatsächlich auch Sachen suchen.
Richtig oldschool Frank.
Und gucke, ob vielleicht sich wer meldet,
der bereit ist, seine Hardware, Smartphones,
was auch immer abzugeben.
eBay-Kleinanzeigen.
Suche kostenlose Laptop.
Für umsonst.
Möglichst gratis.
Wenn man mal ganz kurz hier auf eBay-Kleinanzeigen guckt,
sieht man, dass es wirklich einige Leute gibt, die sowas versuchen,
aber meistens tatsächlich auch erfolgreich ist,
kann ich aus Erfahrung sprechen.
Und ich werde, wie gesagt, in diesem Video einfach mal selber
das nochmal versuchen und gucken,
wie viel Hardware, PCs, was auch immer,
man tatsächlich gratis bekommt.
Als erstes muss ich natürlich eine Anzeige erstellen
und das mache ich jetzt einfach mal.
Und ich werde das Ganze mal benennen.
Ja, ich suche PCs, Smartphones und Laptops,
weil das so die Sachen sind, mit denen ich gerne rumbastele,
mit denen ich gerne was mache.
Ob sich da Leute melden.
Dann natürlich noch eine schöne Beschreibung.
Das ist der Anreiz. Warum geht man auf eBay und sagt,
ah ja, da sucht einer einen kostenlosen PC,
ich fahre da mal vorbei und gebe dem einen.
Gut, wenn du ihn loswerden willst.
Aber wenn ich ihn kostenlos loswerden will,
dann würde ich ihn sogar lieber noch auf den Müll schmeißen,
als zu irgendjemanden hinzufahren
oder den abholen zu lassen oder sonst was.
Also ich würde es wahrscheinlich einfach in Müll schmeißen.
Ich würde es kaputt machen und in Müll schmeißen.
Dass dann keiner meinen Müll rumwühlt.
Wo sollen die Geräte abgeholt werden?
Sollten sie gratis sein?
Auch das Ganze möglichst nett.
Und dann natürlich noch Fotos hinzufügen.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, ich nehme einfach mal Symbolfotos.
Die mache ich natürlich selber.
Ich nehme also erstmal drei Rechner, mache davon ein Foto.
Dann ein Laptop, mache davon ein Foto.
Dann Smartphones und mache davon auch ein Foto.
Das Ganze dann auch schön zuschneiden.
Und zack, ist die Anzeige auch schon fertig.
Und ja, dann müssen wir sie einfach aufgeben.
Das mache ich jetzt auch einfach mal.
Und dann mal gucken, ob sich wer meldet.
Nach drei Stunden hatte die Anzeige schon 42 Aufrufe und wurde schon dreimal gemerkt.
Und ja, ob ihr es glaubt oder nicht, ich habe schon eine Anfrage bekommen,
wo jemand anscheinend einen defekten Laptop abzugeben hat.
Das hat mich natürlich auch sehr interessiert.
Und so wie ich bin, ich frage eigentlich in der Regel immer nach Fotos vorher,
damit ich einschätzen kann, ist es das wert.
Zum Beispiel, wenn das jetzt irgendwas ist, mit dem ich gar nichts machen kann
und ich dann ganz weit fahre, nur um das abzuholen, ist das auch irgendwie doof.
Aber als er mir dann tatsächlich die Fotos geschickt hat...
Wahrscheinlich wieder 500 Kilometer gefahren für einen kostenlosen Notebook.
Konnte ich meinen Augen gar nicht trauen.
Ja, das sieht doch ganz gut aus.
Und ja, ich habe es richtig gesehen.
Der wollte tatsächlich diesen Laptop einfach verschenken.
Und ich meine, selbst wenn der einen Totalschaden hat,
das ist Core i Serie, mindestens sechste Generation.
Also das war wirklich Wahnsinn.
Ja, und das Gespräch ist auch gut verlaufen.
Er hat gesagt, ich kann den Laptop am nächsten Tag abholen.
Und das hat mich wirklich sehr gefreut.
Ihr könnt euch das gar nicht vorstellen.
Dann am nächsten Morgen, dem Tag darauf, habe ich dann noch eine Anfrage bekommen.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, dass manche Leute einfach nett sind.
Also, man kann sich...
Ich persönlich kann mir das schlecht vorstellen,
weil ich nicht nett oder Kontakt mit fremden Leuten da irgendwie haben will.
Aber ich glaube, manche Leute sind einfach nett.
Ich habe Teile vom PC, nur Abholung.
Wer kennt sich PC-Teile?
Z.B. noch einer, der gesagt hat, yo, du kannst das haben.
Er hat mir Hardware-Teile angeboten.
Gut, also mit Rechtschreiben muss man sich eh verabschieden auf eBay klein anzeigen.
Wobei ich damit überhaupt kein Problem habe.
Ihr kennt meine Tweets, die sind auch nicht gerade sonderlich...
High-Fade-Grammatik.
Wie ihr hier auch erkennen könnt.
Und das war jetzt nicht wirklich special.
Aber da das tatsächlich im gleichen Ort lag und nicht so weit entfernt war,
habe ich überlegt, yo, das nehme ich dann auch noch mit.
Also habe ich das auch klar gemacht.
LC-Power, LC-Power-Netzteil, Leute.
Ich sage es euch.
Das smoket, das raucht ab nach Einschalten.
Ja, leider habe ich jetzt nicht wirklich was beim Abholen aufgenommen.
Deswegen gehen wir jetzt direkt wieder hier zu mir nach Hause.
Und ich zeige euch einfach mal, was ich so alles bekommen habe.
So, ich bin jetzt hier wieder zu Hause.
Und wie ihr auch schon erkennen könnt, ich habe noch ein bisschen mehr mitgenommen als nur die Sachen, die ich erwähnte.
Erstmal zu Netto.
Z.B. auch dieses Soundsystem oder die Mäuse.
Weil der eine eBay-Typ hat mir da noch ein bisschen mehr gegeben.
Der eBay-Typ hat gesagt, wenn sie gerade schon da sind, nehmen sie den ganzen Scheiß mit.
Links den PC als erstes anschauen.
Danach die PC-Teile.
Danach das Soundsystem.
Und danach die Mäuse und den Laptop, weil das Beste kommt zum Schluss.
Ja, der Rechner, wie auch schon auf dem Foto erkennbar war, war ein Acer.
Und der war auch jedenfalls auch witzig verpackt hier.
Oder Archer, wie meine Oma immer gesagt hat.
Und beim Rausnehmen ist der halbe Rechner mir schon zusammengefallen.
Das war ein bisschen komisch.
Allgemein waren auch irgendwie die Seitenbände nicht richtig dran.
Also irgendwas ist damit auf jeden Fall passiert.
Wie man hier vorne erkennen kann, ist verbaut oder sollte verbaut sein.
Ein Quad, zwei Quad.
Meine Oma hat immer gesagt Archer.
Eine ATI-Radion-Karte und Windows Vista.
Aber ob da noch eine Festplatte oder irgendwas der Teile drin ist, weiß ich natürlich nicht.
Okay, das ist ziemlich alles Zeug.
Weil wir haben hier an der Frontblende, was ja ziemlich einfach war.
Aber Hauptsache erst einmal zwei DVD-Laufwerke.
Dann noch zwei Laufwerke.
Und ja, der Kartenleser, der vorne eigentlich drin sein sollte, hat gefehlt.
Auf der Rückseite des PCs haben wir ein normales Netzteil.
PS2, aber schon USB.
USB ist am Start.
Wahrscheinlich zwei, wenn man Glück hat schon.
DVI, VGA.
Das sieht aus wie so ein PC von 2008 oder so.
VGA, viermal USB, einmal Ethernet und drei Audioanschlüsse.
Ebenso wie noch eine LAN-Karte, so wie es aussieht, die unten verbaut ist.
Und das Öffnen des Rechners war wirklich, wirklich schwer.
Nämlich die ganze Seitenwand hat geklemmt, wie sonst was.
Aber als ich ihn dann aufbekommen habe, habe ich auch gesehen...
Ah, guck mal hier.
Der hat es richtig. Der hat so einen Schraubenzieher mit...
Wie heißt das? VDE-Ausführung?
Wie nennt man das denn? Mit die Isoliertes?
Aber als ich ihn dann aufbekommen habe, habe ich auch gesehen,
da ist nicht mehr die Original-Hardware verbaut.
Damit ist schon irgendwas passiert, bzw. der wurde auf jeden Fall umgebaut.
In den RAM-Slots waren außerdem zwei unterschiedliche RAM-Regeln verbaut.
Und eine Festplatte war leider auch nicht mehr drin.
Ich habe den Rechner also angeschaltet, mit dem On-Off-Knopf, der hier so halb raushängt,
weil er oben nicht mehr angeschlossen ist.
Besser On-Off-Knopf.
Das könnte auch anders sein. Der Rechner ging nicht an, also wirklich gar nichts.
Keine LED, kein Lüfter.
Und da habe ich immer schon gedacht, oh, da ist bestimmt irgendwas richtig faul.
Da ist wahrscheinlich einfach irgendwas nicht richtig angesteckt.
Was ich als erstes gesehen habe, war, dass der CPU-Lüfter tatsächlich gar nicht
an den vorgesehenen Anschluss angeschlossen wurde,
sondern an den Anschluss für einen Gehäuse-Lüfter.
Und was ich dann auch gesehen habe, oh, das, was ich gedrückt habe,
war tatsächlich der Reset-Button. Der On-Off-Button hat komplett gefehlt.
Und ich habe dann auch den Reset-Button.
Also ich könnte mir tatsächlich vorstellen, dass der Kram funktioniert.
Man glaubt das gar nicht, aber Hardware ist, wenn man da keine Löcher reinmacht
oder irgendwie ist wirklich, dass Komponenten davon abfallen oder so.
Einfach nur, wenn Hardware rumsteht, geht Hardware, meine Erfahrung nach,
zumindest so gut wie nicht kaputt.
Also du kannst eigentlich einen PC, also hätte irgendjemand
ein 486er-PC vor 40 Jahren auf den Dachboden gestellt.
Man würde den heute runterholen und anschließen.
Die Chancen, dass der geht, wären relativ hoch.
Einfach auf die Pins für den On-Off-Button gesteckt
und dann ist der Rechner tatsächlich auch angegangen.
Das Bild kam allerdings erst nach circa einer Minute, aber es kam, da war ich schon glücklich.
Nach einer Minute?
Da kann man auch mal kurz sehen, wir haben einen AMD Atlon Dual Core Prozessor 5050e.
Das heißt, wir haben eine AMD-Plattform und keine Intel-Plattform mehr,
wie das Gehäuse ja vormunkelt.
Auch ins BIOS kommen wir rein und wie man auch schon sieht,
wir haben ein Gigabyte RAM.
Das liegt daran, dass ich den 1-Gigabyte rausgebaut habe,
da er sonst nicht angehen will, also ist das wahrscheinlich auch ein Fehler.
Aber ansonsten funktioniert der Rechner, da habe ich jetzt eigentlich keinen Zweifel dran.
Die Sache ist nur die.
Du hast das Ding jetzt zwar kostenlos auf eBay bekommen,
aber was willst du denn damit machen?
Also ich meine, du hast den dann ja schön und gut und dann?
Also und weiter?
But why?
Also was denn jetzt?
Bitcoin meine ich, das bringt es ja damit nicht.
Ich weiß, es ist Gigabyte, aber was willst du machen?
Also was machst du damit dann im Endeffekt?
Basteln?
Ja, der hat wahrscheinlich aber schon 50 Bastelrechner.
Mit 20 Festplatten steht das, selbst dafür lohnt sich das nicht.
Was ich mit dem Rechner mache, muss ich mal gucken.
Das ist ja ein ziemliches Rack.
Du kannst eigentlich nichts machen.
Das funktioniert ja anscheinend noch.
Also mal gucken, kann man sicherlich irgendwie weiterverwenden.
Aber ich glaube, das Gehäuse kann ich wirklich entsorgen,
weil das hat abgebrochene Stellen.
Für was willst du es halt verwenden?
Es gibt halt nichts.
Als nächstes kommen wir zu den PC-Teilen, die ja vom gleichen eBay-Typ stammen.
Und ich mache hier mal kurz einen Schnelldurchlauf der Teile, die wir bekommen haben.
Testen werde ich die jetzt nicht.
Das sind CPUs von 2005 oder so, da könnte sogar ein aktueller Raspberry Pi schneller sein.
Als erstes haben wir ein Asus A8NE-FMS für den Sockel 939 ohne CPU.
RAM ist auch nicht verbaut und IO-Blende fehlt soweit, ich weiß auch.
Aber vielleicht ist hier noch...
Was ist denn das hier für ein Ding?
Ich würde sagen, das ist ein Sound-Ausgang eigentlich.
So einen...
Ich habe vorhin vergessen, wie die Dinger heißen, aber warum hat es hier so einen komischen...
SPDIF, ja, kann sein, aber so ein Analoga noch.
Das, was es heute eigentlich nur per TOS-Link gibt.
Ist das ein Firewire-Anschluss?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Das ist doch Firewire.
Okay, das ist Oldschool.
Ob es noch ein Firewire-Anschluss ist?
Ähm...
Ja, das war noch aus Zeiten, wo Mainboards braun oder gelb...
Äh, braun oder grün oder blau waren.
Da war es noch nicht so, dass die irgendwie Killer-Fatality-Headshot-Eyescopes-Pro hießen
und irgendwelche komischen silber verplendeten Dinger drauf hatten.
...noch in der Tüte drin.
Ich denke mal, das Mainboard wird wahrscheinlich noch funktionieren, aber ich werde es jetzt wie gesagt nicht testen.
Als nächstes haben wir, so wie es aussieht, das Mainboard für den Acer-Rechner tatsächlich,
weil verbaut ist ein Core 2 Quad.
Und was mich auch gewundert hat, auf dem Mainboard liegt einfach die CPU rum.
Und wie sich rausschließen lässt, ist das tatsächlich die CPU für das Asus-Board.
Also, die ist einfach nur abgefallen aus irgendeinem Grund.
Die CPU ist leider unfassbar beschädigt, bzw. die Pins sind verbogen.
Ich glaube, das kann man reparieren, aber ob es anwärts ist...
Wozu? Wozu?
Als nächstes haben wir hier 2x 1GB DDR400-RAM.
Weiterhin waren noch 3 Festplatten in der Tüte, 2 Seagate und eine Mac-Store.
Wenn du die anschließt, findest du massig private Sachen.
Die Leute sind da so leichtsinnig.
Allerdings hören die sich nicht mehr wirklich gut an, wenn man die...
Festplatten, die kaputt sind, immer noch der beste Ort.
Festplatten... Ich versuche das mal kurz nachzustellen.
Festplatten, die angeht und kaputt sind, die machen meistens am Anfang...
Also starten und dann macht es auf einmal...
Und dann weißt du...
Okay, RIP.
Ein bisschen neigt, dann hört man darin schon so ein komisches Klicken.
Ich glaube nicht mehr, dass die funktionieren...
Der erste Klick ist normal.
Das dreht an...
Und dann ab einer gewissen Geschwindigkeit klappt das Zeug irgendwie aus.
Der erste Klick...
Dieser erste Klick...
Und dann...
Ist normal.
Bei der Festplatte.
Du kannst dann weiter die ganze Zeit machen...
Dann weißt du... RIP.
Stimmt, irgendwie da rumgeschüttelt worden im Karton.
Ich habe zwar sehr aufgepasst, aber...
Ich sehe in dem Chat, gefällt meine Interpretation der Festplattengeräusche.
Ich glaube, die sind kaputt.
Als letztes in der Tüte waren noch...
Pass mal auf, das meine ich.
Broken HDD Sound.
Gibt es bestimmt hier Alt-Sound. Ja!
Was ist das?
Alter!
Ist da Wein?
Boah!
RIP.
Danke für den Sub.
Hip Hop. Hippo.
Drei Monate. Poggers.
Das da!
Das ist schlecht.
Der will das doch nicht mit Aufschrauben reparieren.
Wenn du das Ding aufschraubst, ist das Ding ja meistens auch mehr im Arsch danach.
Da hast du erstmal schönen Staub und alles hier oben drauf.
In der Regel kannst du sagen, wenn du hier aufschreibst, ist das recht kaputt.
Das ist recht kaputt.
Der will doch nicht wirklich behaupten,
der hat die jetzt repariert.
Nee.
I cannot find a problem.
Reparieren und dann repariert er es gar nicht.
Zwei Netzteile.
Ist LC-Power China-Chinesen-Kram?
Das sieht aus wie so ein typisches billig LC-Power Netzteil.
Ob die einen Nutzen finden, weiß ich jetzt natürlich nicht.
So, das sind jetzt alle Teile.
Das einzig interessante wäre hier natürlich der Core 2 Quad.
Und vielleicht auch ein paar der RAM-Riegel könnte ich noch...
Was ist denn mit dem Notebook?
Die CPU kann man wie gesagt auch noch reparieren.
Insgesamt ja zum Basteln sicherlich ganz interessant.
So, als nächstes kommen wir zu dem Soundsystem hier.
Das hat der ja in einen Karton reingepackt.
Und es ist auch wirklich ziemlich schwer.
Und ich werde das Ganze jetzt einfach mal auspacken und aufbauen.
Ob ich es testen kann, weiß ich nicht.
Aber mal gucken.
So, das Ganze habe ich jetzt erstmal ausgepackt.
Es scheint ein 5.1 Soundsystem zu sein.
Auch mit dem Receiver.
Und ich kenne mich jetzt nicht wirklich.
Das alte Zeug ist oftmals gar nicht so schlecht.
Soundmäßig.
Ich werde das Ganze jetzt mal so weit wie es geht aufbauen.
Und gucken, ob ich damit irgendwas machen kann.
Okay, ich habe das Ganze aufgebaut.
Und wie ihr auch schon sehen könnt, es geht auch an.
Und es kommt auch so ein Rauschen, besonders wenn man die Lautstärke hochdreht.
Das Problem ist, dass ich das Ganze jetzt nicht wirklich auf die Schnelle testen kann.
Ich nehme aber mal an, dass es noch funktioniert.
Ich meine, warum sollte sowas kaputt sein?
Und da gibt es ja ganz viele Ersatzteile auch dazu.
Aber ich denke mal...
Macht der Note an an und verkauft wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich verstehe den Sinn davon auch nicht.
Aber der Sinn ist ja schon mal hier ganz gut zu sehen.
Er kann wenigstens YouTube-Videos von machen.
Ich meine, das ist ja auch eine Möglichkeit.
Ob ich damit was anfangen kann, muss ich mal gucken.
Ansonsten werde ich es weiter verschenken.
So, jetzt kommen wir zum großen Finale.
Und zwar zu dem Laptop und den Mäusen.
Ich glaube, darauf habt ihr auch schon gewartet.
Weil der Laptop ist jetzt wirklich...
Ich kann es kaum noch erwarten.
Ich würde mal sagen, ich stelle euch erst mal kurz die Mäuse vor.
Nein, who cares?
Weniger Mäuse.
Ich dachte so, okay.
Und ja, beim Aufmachen zeigt sich natürlich erst mal der Laptop selber.
Ebenfalls aber noch drin sind noch die Bedienungsanleitung.
Und das Aufladekabel.
Also das komplette Set.
Ich weiß wirklich nicht, warum ihr das abgibt.
Aber kann ja sein, dass der Laptop total Schaden hat.
Dann könnte ich es auch irgendwie verstehen.
Beim Aufklappen des Laptops zeigt sich auch...
Er sieht...
Volkratzare sieht echt noch gut in Schuss aus.
Er hat keine Kratzer.
Oder irgendwas.
Und wie man unten rechts auch sehen kann, das habe ich auch echt nicht fassen können.
Weil ich wusste zwar, irgendein Core i-Series verbaut.
Aber ein Core i7.
Und dann auch noch so ein neuer.
Das hat mich wirklich sehr gewundert.
Wie schon gesagt sieht der Laptop relativ gut aus.
Das Display auch noch.
Auf der Unterseite sieht der Laptop auch noch ganz gut aus.
Und was die Ports angeht, haben wir einmal den Stromanschluss.
Ein Ethernet-Port.
Ein HDMI-Anschluss.
Ein USB-Port.
Und ein Kartenleser.
Und auf der anderen Seite noch ein Kopfhöreranschluss.
Zwei USB-Anschlüsse.
Ein CD-Laufwerk bzw. DVD-Laufwerk.
Und ein Kensington-Log.
Beim ersten Versuch den Laptop anzuschalten über den Akku, ist natürlich nichts passiert.
Weil es vermutlich auch schon leer war.
Aber ich habe den Laptop dann an das Ladekabel angeschlossen.
Und unten links kam tatsächlich eine weiße LED.
Was ja schon mal ein sehr gutes Zeichen ist.
Dass er zumindest erkennt, dass was angeschlossen wurde.
Und beim Anschalten habe ich es tatsächlich selber nicht glauben können.
Aber der Laptop ging an.
Nach einer Zeit kam dann tatsächlich der Ladebalken von Windows 10.
Und nach einer Zeit war ich dann auch immer mit...
Wahrscheinlich immer noch komplett mit User-Daten und allem.
Die Leute so leicht wie ich.
Also er ist ganz normal angegangen.
Als ob er einfach gestern runtergefahren wurde.
Guck mal das ist sogar ein Windows 10 noch.
Das Touchpad hat funktioniert.
Die Tastatur funktioniert bei der Passwort-Eingabe.
Also das Gerät war wirklich noch einwandfrei am Laufen.
Natürlich kann ich jetzt hier nicht viel machen.
Deswegen werde ich jetzt erstmal ins BIOS gehen.
Und wie man hier auch schon erkennen kann.
Haben wir ein Core i7 6500U.
Eine 1TB HD.
Was ist denn das für ein BIOS?
Das ist ein richtiges Monarch S BIOS.
Das ist das.
Wie bei den ersten EFI BIOS-Dingern.
Als die festgestellt haben.
Man kann jetzt ja ein bisschen grafisch machen.
Und Maus-Support und so.
Dann haben die quasi Windows-Menüs nachgebaut.
Richtig, richtiger Paints-Champ.
Ein ordentlicher Laptop.
Ich habe dann Windows 9 installiert.
Aber die Installation mit der HDD hat wirklich ewig gebraucht.
Also wirklich sehr, sehr lange.
Untypisch lange.
Deswegen habe ich einfach die HDD rausgebaut und eine SSD reingebaut.
Und hier kann man mal kurz sehen.
Jetzt flutscht es mit SSD.
Also sehr gut austauschbar.
RAM, selbst BIOS-Batterie.
Und den Akku kann man auch noch rausnehmen.
Und nach dem Einbau der SSD habe ich dann Windows 10 installiert.
Und es läuft einwandfrei.
Ich habe bei der Installation gar keine Probleme gehabt.
Diesen USB-Stick, Leute.
Wer hatte den auch schon?
Ich sage jetzt.
50 Leute schreien jetzt hier.
Weil diese Sorte USB-Sticks.
Das ist der typische Billig-China-Chinesen-USB-Stick.
Den hatte jeder schon mal.
Jeder hatte den. Und die sind schlecht.
Die sind richtig schlecht, diese Dinger.
Die Frage ist eher, wer nicht?
Wer nicht?
Ich frage mich wirklich echt, warum hat er den weggeworfen?
Beziehungsweise, warum hat er ihn mir geschenkt?
Ich, neugierig wie ich bin, habe ihn tatsächlich nochmal gefragt.
Was der mit dem Laptop eigentlich sei.
Weil das hat er mir gar nicht gesagt. Auch vor Ort nicht.
Und er meinte dann,
dass er den Rechner mal gebraucht gekauft hat.
Weil er nicht mal nicht richtig hochgefahren ist.
Und dann irgendwann gar nicht mehr ging.
Aber anscheinend geht er ja jetzt einwandfrei.
Und bisher konnte ich auch keine Defekte feststellen.
Auch beim Installing der Classic-Treiber von AMD.
Hier ist übrigens verbaut eine AMD Radeon R5 M335.
Ich glaube, es ist auch nicht so schlecht.
Und ich hoffe mal, das bleibt auch so.
Um eine gute Funktion zu gewährleisten,
werde ich den Laptop jetzt noch den Abend hier testen.
Und werde euch dann morgen,
beziehungsweise jetzt gleich im Video,
mal kurz das Ergebnis sagen,
ob das noch alles gut funktioniert.
Weil der Laptop muss ja auch ein bisschen getestet werden.
Und mal gucken, ob er dann immer noch geht.
So, jetzt hier am nächsten Tag.
Ich melde mich wieder. Und tatsächlich,
der Laptop hat keine Probleme gemacht.
Einmal ist er ausgegangen.
Der Akku leer war. Und da kommen wir auch schon zum nächsten Thema.
Der Akku funktioniert auch.
Ist zwar nicht mehr der beste, aber immer noch brauchbar.
Ich habe gestern auch auf dem Minecraft gespielt.
Und es hat auch funktioniert.
Na gut, Minecraft. Na gut, das stimmt gar nicht.
Minecraft ist tatsächlich viel anspruchsvoller,
wenn man so denkt.
Also der Laptop scheint wieder sehr gut zu laufen.
Ich kann es mir, wie gesagt, immer noch nicht erklären.
Aber ich würde mal sagen, Jackpot,
in Zukunft werde ich ihn auf jeden Fall noch etwas weiter nutzen.
Und euch dann vielleicht irgendwann mal wieder sagen,
ob das Ganze noch funktioniert.
Aber das ist wirklich eine der besten,
ich sag mal, Funde, die ich jemals hatte.
So nice.
Damit kann man wenigstens was anfangen im Vergleich
zu dem anderen Programm.
Alter, die sieht ein bisschen versifft aus.
Ja.
Das ist nichts, was man jetzt nicht bereinigen könnte.
Und beim Anstecken
ist tatsächlich nichts passiert, also dachte ich,
die Maus ist vielleicht auch einfach kaputt.
Aber beim zweiten Anstecken, warum auch immer,
kam dann unten eine rote Beleuchtung und die Maus ging einwandfrei.
Also ich weiß nicht genau, was da los war.
Auch bei Installation der Rocket
Treiber, das habe ich jetzt hier nicht gezeigt,
funktioniert die Maus sehr gut.
Allerdings kann ich aus irgendeinem Grund die Beleuchtung
nur in verschiedene Farben ändern.
Und ich glaube so 70% der Farben
funktionieren nicht. Ich weiß nicht, woran es liegt, aber
der Maus ist auf jeden Fall gewährleistet.
Also wenn RGB nicht geht, ist ja quasi gleich kaputt.
Ohne RGB, wer will denn sowas?
Scheiße.
Echt pock. So, jetzt gucken wir zum Schluss nochmal eine Runde
Battlefield 3 Topplays. Da habe ich jetzt nochmal Bock drauf.
Zack, in the Cop.
Next, in the Cop.
Alter, da werden sie weggesprayt.
Zack.
Sehr nice.
Next.
SV-98 ACOG.
Das sieht man auch selten
im BF3.
Zack, wir müssen noch was gucken.
Was meint ihr, wie viele Spieler
hat Venice heute?
Wie viele Spieler hat Venice heute? Also ich tippe auf
meistbesuchter Server hat
drei Spieler. Ja, drei.
Drei Spieler würde ich auch sagen.
Vier.
Oder nicht.
Zack.
Comeback, comeback.
Ja, es ist ja auch ein gutes Game.
Ist ja auch ein gutes Game.
Kein Wunder, dass das noch Leute spielen.
Warum hast du es noch nicht
deinstalliert? Warum sollte ich?
Kannst du einfach ab und zu mal eingucken.
Kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Zack.
Er muss mit dem
Fuß schießen oder was?
Das war jetzt aber kein Topplay.
Ah, das kommt jetzt wahrscheinlich.
Das huge play.
Jawoll, Spawnpunkt, Spawnpunkt.
Die Gegner checken es wieder nicht. Excellent, excellent.
So muss das sein.
Oh.
Ich dachte, es gibt jetzt Collateral.
Durch drei Gegner durch.
Der benutzt sogar seine Drohne.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Gibt es selten.
Nice.
Sein paar Killstreaks sind selten.
Ah.
Rex, beste.
Weggerext.
Nice.
Deswegen Magisch Battle für drei.
Alter, die werden ja
weggesprayt, die Leute.
Das ist nicht der Spawn von denen.
Der Spawn von denen ist da hinten.
Wenn sie Base Spawn hier hinten.
Die Spawn absichtlich bei den Leuten
und lassen sich bashen.
Der ist gut.
Wenigstens labert er heute nicht dabei.
Das finde ich nice.
Aber Metro ist halt immer Metro, ne?
Da man von der Auflösung hört,
könnte es fast Xbox sein.
Es ist aber PC.
Der Sound,
der Sound von Battlefield drei
ist auch nice.
Das hat mir ja in Battlefield 2042
noch ein bisschen gefehlt.
Oh.
M416, beste.
Brrrr.
Eine Tingos.
Das macht Big Shock eigentlich.
Nice.
M16, M416.
Das war ein bisschen...
Natürlich hatte Battlefield drei OP-Shit.
M16 war OP.
Aber es war zumindest
noch ein bisschen
Variation drin.
Du konntest M416 spielen, M16 spielen,
AEK spielen.
Das ist schon mal ganz gut.
Du konntest sowas wie AS-VAL
auch verschiedene Sachen spielen.
Bei den Engineer-Waffen, P90.
Du hattest schon,
sagen wir mal, so sechs,
sieben Dinger.
Das reicht eigentlich.
Viel mehr wirst du eh nicht
balanced kriegen.
Zumal was cool war,
du hattest ganz klar Schwerpunkte
der Waffen und das hat auch funktioniert.
Du hattest eine M16, das war natürlich allround.
OP ist Fuck, das ist natürlich die beste Waffe im Spiel.
Aber du hattest sowas wie eine AEK,
die die schon,
oder eine AN-94 oder sowas,
die die schon schlagen konnte, wenn du
dir Mühe gegeben hast.
Natürlich allroundmäßig war das einfach
besser als alles andere.
Du hattest eine M416, die alle M16-Leute
gespielt haben, die nicht geschimpft
bekommen wollten, dass sie OP-Waffen spielen.
Ja, nice.
Und die Pistolen gingen halt auch gut ab.
Alter, was ein Krach.
Und das war, was ich halt
richtig mag am Battlefield 3.
Das ist halt richtig schön
fast-paced.
Du kannst da nicht, also du musst da nicht
ewig rumstellen und du bist
auch schnell wieder in der Action.
Selbst wenn du 5x auf den Sack kriegst, weil unkünstiger Spawn.
Das 6. Mal
kriegst du da einen guten Flank hin,
machst irgendwie 15 Kills oder so.
Der ganze Spielfluss
und die Maps und das alles im Gesamtpaket
war einfach richtig schnell im Battlefield 3.
Siebertower.
Revive Train.
Den ich ja persönlich gut fand.
Da musste nicht viel machen und hat trotzdem Teamplay
quasi gefördert.
Weil wer Revived
in Battlefield, jetzt mal ernsthaft,
wie oft
wurde in Battlefield 2042
beta Revived?
Ich denke mal insgesamt wurde ich vielleicht
10x Revived, wenn es hochkommt.
Und ich hab selbst vielleicht auch 10x
Revived.
Wo ist der Huge Play? Bam.
Gesprüht und gebetet hier.
Das war typische Battlefield Head Hit Detection.
Er ist eigentlich schon weg
und stirbt dann noch.
Jawoll.
Siehst du,
so muss das mit dem Wiederbeleben sein.
Ansonsten ist es doch, guck mal,
wie hätte der jetzt hier wirklich
diese 10 Sekunden Battlefield
2042 Wiederbelebung machen sollen,
da wären die doch alle verreckt.
Einfach hin,
weiter, zack.
Das sind 2 Sekunden, fördert
Teamplay und
pack dich nicht selbst
in die Ass.
Natürlich war es OP, aber das hatten
alle Seiten. Ich hab da, also
es fand ich jetzt wenig problematisch in
die 3.
100 HP
Reviven
konnte nur
dieser eine Specialist, den man hatte.
Angeblich.
Laut DICE Beschreibung.
Und der andere Specialist,
der andere Medic Specialist, den es jetzt gibt,
kann Reviven,
aber Reviven an sich kann ja jeder.
Der Sound war richtig leise,
oder?
Hä?
Ich hab's nicht gecheckt.
Hat der gerade was gekillt? Ich hab's nicht gecheckt.
Hat der, hä?
Hitte das jetzt gleich noch, oder was?
Ich hab noch nichts gesehen.
Oh, nice!
Das war cool.
Das machst du, das musst du halt
500 mal machen, dass es halt immer klappt.
Okay, ein bisschen übertrieben.
50 mal, 100 mal.
Ja, gut.
Das war gut Glück.
Das war auch gut Glück. Der Volt,
den zwar hinten und hat in die Richtung gezielt,
aber das war trotzdem viel Glück dabei.
Das war jetzt nicht auf dem Millimeter
calculated.
Ja, schon wieder.
Intervention.
Rust, one on one, Intervention only.
Bam!
Zack!
Dude, dude, dude.
Wir haben reingerannt,
das ist ein Snowscope.
Oh!
Alter, da lassen sie sich von hinten
aber richtig
durchnehmen.
Ich finde die Ego-Perspektiven
die Ego-Perspektiven-Knives
viel besser als dieser Person.
Übrigens, in Battlefield 2042,
wenn man lang drückt,
dann macht man die
Kill-Animation, ich glaube, wenn man kurz drückt,
dann gibt es die Kill-Animation aus der Ego-Perspektive.
Also ist es beides
drinne, oder war es umgedreht?
Zack!
In den Sack geschossen!
Wollte ich gerade sagen,
in den Sack geschossen.
Könnt ihr euch noch an meinen Ingame-Namen
in Battlefield 3 erinnern?
Auf dem PC?
Nee, in BZ2!
In BZ2 war es glaube ich.
Da hieß ich aus irgendwelchen Gründen
Info-Hoden.
Ich habe keine Ahnung warum.
Fällt mir nur gerade so
ein richtig hängen gebliebener
Name.
Info-Hoden.
Da sitzt er in der Ecke.
Ah, er!
Ok, Smoke.
Der hat bestimmt Smoke am Start.
Der smoke immer die halbe Map,
aber es ist immer noch viel Spaß
auf Conquest.
Ich habe jetzt echt Bock Battlefield 3
zu spielen.
Ich glaube, ich esse jetzt Wasser und spiele
ich Baron Battlefield 3.
Der spielt immer AIK und am besten
dann noch Smoke.
Aber kann kein Smoke spielen, weil er hat
andere Gadgets dabei.
Man sieht nichts, es ist so dunkel.
Clip hätte er ein bisschen
heller machen können.
Ein bisschen Helligkeits Officer
drüber.
Da sieht es zwar milchiger aus,
aber man erkennt mehr.
Alter, wenn es gesprayt.
So musst es sein.
Boah, Alter.
Kriegen die auf den Sack!
Wir sind ganz auf dem Sack.
auf dem Sack
WTF
Krass, das war ein nicer play
Das Ding hat ja kaum einer gespielt
M417
Jetzt ist er suppressed
Suppression
Alter, wenn die weggesprayt
Fuck, Alter, die haben richtig
Die wurden richtig weg
Gachibust
Domi, danke für den Zap
Alter
Alter, die kriegen auch auf dem Sack
Nice
Das waren jetzt irgendwie 30 Kills in 2 Minuten
Was? Wie ist der andere Typ im Squad?
Lord of the...
Naja
Belfett rein haben halt
Weil es Metro ist
Ich bin ja kein so großer Metro Fan
Fuck
Alter, die werden auch...
Das war jetzt alles
Ich wollte gerade sagen, was jetzt
Nice
Schon wieder Magnum in den Kopf
Ich glaube mir hat wenig
Also mir hat in kaum einem Spiel
Es so viel Bock gemacht
Wenn du mal richtig abgegangen bist
In Battlefield 3
Ich mein, ohne macht in jedem Spiel Bock
Aber Battlefield 3 war schon was besonderes
In der Richtung
Du konntest in Battlefield 3
Auch so unglaublich viel durch
Laufwege und Timing machen
Was mir zugute kommt mit 37 mittlerweile
Laufwege und Timing kann man mit 37 auch noch
Jetzt das super krasse Headshot
Five Head Flick
Twitch, Aim
Mit 40 bist du alt
Ab 40 habe ich deinen Commander Krieger Aim
Hast du eigentlich deinen BLE Thermostat
Wieder gefixt bekommen?
Ja, hab ich
Du kannst
Die offizielle Firmware zurückflaschen
Die Dinger sind nämlich noch erreichbar
Über Bluetooth
Und mittlerweile gibt es auch
Eine neue Firmware, die
Die Revision unterstützt
Das Flaschen wird demnächst
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob wir das heute noch
Flaschen oder nicht
Keine Ahnung
Ludel
So
Der Harald
Ist am Start
Moin
So
Was machen wir jetzt?
Ich würde sagen, ich gehe jetzt essen
Richtig
Peppofett
Richtig hoste
NordVP
Ja, den können wir tatsächlich hosten, was macht der denn gerade?
Bluetooth Reverse Engineering
Exzellent
TCP Dump macht er
TCP Dump
Bluetooth stellt
Big Brain Time
Ok, hosten wir ihn
Raid
Ja, exzellent
Was macht eigentlich der Frasier?
Was macht der Frasier?
Der Frasier war vor zwei Tagen
Der hat irgendwelche Weep Games gespielt, alles klar
Ok Leute, wir sehen uns vielleicht heute Abend nochmal
Vielleicht flaschen wir dann wirklich
Die Thermometer wieder
Also bis denn Leute, wir sehen uns
heute Abend nochmal, bis denn Leute, wir sehen uns